the governor of Texas has issued a
statement with a formal letter that the
president of the United States has
violated his oath of office and they are
actively committing crimes for this
Texas has declared its right to
self-defense of its border declaring
Supremacy over the jurisdiction they're
saying that Texas's right to
self-defense supersedes Federal orders
oh boy there are now many prominent
leftists calling for accountability in
in fact one Democrat has once again
asserted the federal government should
seize the Texas National Guard oh man
you know when we talk about the the the
hyperpolarization in this country and
what it could bubble up into we are now
looking at the rather rare and shocking
circumstance of the State National Guard
of Texas armed in opposition to federal
agents where this one goes well we've
been talking about this one quite a bit
so we're going have to talk about that
quite a bit more and there is a a bunch
of other news they're trying to stop
Donald Trump from being able to conduct
business in New York citing the
martinelly case so this should be very
very interesting of course Nikki Haley's
refusing to drop out but along with the
story out of Texas this one's taking the
cake today because Oklahoma has declared
they will stand with Texas and Ronda
santis has also spoken up as the
governor of Florida in defense of Texas
so we got a whole lot going on now
before we get into all that my friends
head over to cast brew.com to buy the
best cup of coffee you will ever have
it's so good in fact that appalachin kns
is sold out of our K Cups and our ground
but it is still available in whole bean
coffee now of course rise with Roberto
Jr our second most popular uh blend it's
a light roast it's available in ground
and the K cups are available but but but
always don't forget Alex Stein's Prime
Time grind two times caffeine coffee for
those that like a little bit of edge
with their coffee drink responsibly my
friends when you buy Cas Brew Coffee not
only are you getting the best cup of
coffee you will ever have considering
we've sold out of Appalachia kns people
really love the stuff thank you so much
but uh you'll be supporting the show so
if you want to support the work we do we
sponsor ourselves Casper is the way to
do it you're also supporting our
Endeavor to launch coffee shops which
are we have one currently under
construction also head over to Tim
cast.com click join us become a member
to support our work directly and you
will get access to our Discord server
and our members only uncensored shows
which come Monday through Thursday at
10: p.m. and you as members can actually
call in talk to us and our guests so
don't forget to also smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is Morgan McMichael hello everybody
glad to be here who are you what are you
doing I am a turning point USA
contributor I live out in Phoenix
Arizona I'm from Texas so I'm super
excited to talk about this border crisis
and everything that's going on because
it's absolutely absurd that our border
is wide open uh and I have been talking
in political media for about two years
I'm 24 young jenzer so excited to get
bring the jenz perspective right on
we'll we'll definitely talk about that
with the election coming up should be
interesting we got Phil hanging out
hello everybody my name is Phil leonti
I'm the lead singer of the heavy metal
band All That Remains I am a very failed
musician anti-communist and
counterrevolutionary say it loud brother
I am you are rock and roll you are gold
packaged content creator all the way
that's right we were making fun of that
term content content creator when they
started calling stuff content let's make
some good content tonight Serge what's
happening Brother yeah let's be uh let's
be content machines shout out to those
guys by the way Ian by the way he didn't
even introduce himself he needs no
introduction right Ian crossin I at.com
let's get into it then here's a story
from cnr.com Governor Abbott Texas's
right to self-defense supersedes any
federal statutes to the contrary Texas
governor Greg Abbott invoked America's
founding fathers while vowing to
continue to secure Texas's Border in a
new statement his message comes two days
after the United States Supreme Court
ruled the federal government could
remove razor wire along the Rio Grand
installed by the state to deter illegal
immigration and drug trafficking as the
bid administration's appeal makes its
way through the court Texas responded by
installing more razor wire on January
23rd quote the federal government has
broken the compact between the United
States and the states the executive
branch of the United States has a
constitutional duty to enforce federal
laws protecting States including
immigration laws on the books right now
President Biden has refused to enforce
those laws and has even violated them
Abbott says Biden has smashed records
for illegal immigration and ignored
Texas's demand that he perform his
constitutional duties
continuing President Biden has violated
his oath to Faithfully execute
immigration laws enacted by Congress
instead of Prosecuting immigrants for
the federal crime of illegal entry
President Biden has sent his lawyers
into federal courts to sue Texas for
taking action to secure the Border
President Biden has instructed his
agencies to ignore Federal statutes that
mandate the Detention of illegal
immigrants the effect is to illegally
allow their nmass parole into the United
States by wasting taxpayer dollars to
tear open Texas's border security
infrastructure President Biden has
enticed illegal IM immigrants from the
28 legal points of Entry along the state
Southern border Bridges where nobody
drowns and into the dangerous water of
the Rio Grand White House Press
Secretary Karen Jean Pierre told
reporters during a briefing on January
23rd the Biden Administration was
certainly glad the Supreme Court had
permitted the federal government to
remove the wire which she called
ineffective approximately 6 million
illegal immigrants have entered the
United States during Biden's 3 years in
office so what we're seeing right now
New York is freaking out Eric Adams says
the immigration crisis will destroy the
city mayor Brian Johnson has been
accused reportedly there's a reporter
who has asserted I'm very careful my
language here he has suffered panic
attacks and had to be hospitalized
because the immigration crisis or as the
immigration crisis is expanding rapidly
in the city and there are many
communities in Chicago many black
communities that are in uproar over the
resources being given out to these
migrants so when you have major Democrat
strongholds outraged over the
immigration crisis Joe Biden publicly
admitting the border is not secure while
actively trying to make it less secure I
don't know what you call this a rogue
executive branch engaged in criminal
activities Accused by Texas the second
largest state in the Union of violating
the
law now we have videos let me see if I
can uh uh pull up one of these these
videos here there's the uh the letter
here we go take a look at this from
Chuck kesto the Texas National Guard
filmed marching where I can only I
believe this is near Eagle Pass it just
says Texas National Guard and uh there
have been many responses to this in fact
I I believe we have the uh Governor
Kevin stit of Oklahoma saying Oklahoma
stands with Texas Ronda santis of course
said if the Constitution really made
States powerless to defend themselves
against an invasion it wouldn't have
been ratified in the first place and
Texas would have never joined the union
when it did Texas is upholding the law
while Biden is flouting it Florida will
keep assisting Texas with personnel and
assets so this is going to get
interesting where are we currently at
three states Florida Oklahoma and Texas
are aligned Texas is declaring Supremacy
over the Border
jurisdiction the question then that
we've been asking for the past several
days will the federal government
actually make moves against the Texas
National
Guard I I don't think so I I showing
that Oklahoma and Florida are willing to
stand by the Texas National Guard and
the Texas government is is fulfilling
and it's also indicative that like any
state that sits by and watches their
federal government seiz control of their
own State troops has got to be like hell
no you can't we can't let the federal
government go rogue rogue is a nice term
can't let the federal government
overstep its bounds and seize our own
State soldiers like those guys pledging
oath to the state to defend and preserve
the state not they're not the federal
government's troops I'm not sure if if
not if the guard does that or not I
don't know how Constitution most likely
but the the the federal government is
Rogue completely yeah the Biden
Administration is is a rogue agency at
this point this is this is I am this is
a fact when the B Administration is
breaking the law to the extent that
Democrats are upset about it despite the
fact they'll defend him for re-election
because these people are insane but when
you have major cities there there there
is a a plurality of those P saying
immigration is the most pressing issue
yeah and people in these cities that are
Democrat left leaning are freaking out
this is this is the unifying force I
mean perhaps we're we're getting Joe
Biden's pulling off an azi mandas for
those who get the reference he is
deciding to become the super villain
that will unify blue and red States
against him maybe maybe by the time the
election comes up the immigration
problem will be so bad that blue States
will beg Donald Trump to help save them
maybe somebody is doing that through
Biden they're creating an ozie mandia
situation where like we're just going to
make Biden the worst of the worst so
that we can actually unify the country
cuz Trump ain't getting it done for
those that don't know the reference azy
mandas is the villain in the Watchmen
graphic novel who stages an alien
invasion to force the Cold War Nations
to unite against a common enemy and so I
don't believe that to be the case I
don't believe that there is anybody
smart enough or I I I genuinely believe
this is completely in line with what
Democrats have been doing for some time
and even though you have blue cities in
major blue States in uproar over this
these people are still blaming
Republicans and they're still backing
Joe Biden I talk to my parents and I
bring them up as just kind of General
Normie watch the MSNBC but they're very
smart they're very adaptable to new
information but they tend to watch just
the TV instead of the internet for their
news they don't and uh I was like this
this migrant this immigration thing is
horrific and they're like yeah it is
horrific both of them and they get their
news from like MSNBC but they were like
is Absolut it's it's too far like what
in the hell is happening kind of thing
like easily that I could I could
probably convince them to not vote for
the guy that's causing it to happen this
is going to be the issue that I think
jenz is going to really wake up to too
because once they see that these
immigrants are the ones that are taking
spaces in America taking over the cities
our cities are increasing in crime and
your tax dollars are directly funding
the immigration crisis as well I mean
Texas had no other choice but to enact
Article 1 Section 10 in the Constitution
because the federal government isn't
doing anything about it and honestly the
federal government hates American people
more than Democrats I think hate
American people because they're the ones
that are creating this havoc in our
country and I mean I saw a poll that
immigration is a bigger issue going into
the election cycle more than in
inflation and I mean we're seeing
inflation rates Skyrocket but I think
people are finally starting to
understand like oh my gosh our border
really is open and what Kareem John
Pierre uh pressac said if it was
ineffective then why move it
inflation is a byproduct of immigration
yeah Mass migration results I mean look
by by by standard economics Mass
migration they even say it will create
demand so you're going to have a ton of
people demanding more and more and more
you're going to drive prices up but the
the best way to explain it we talked
about this before and you can give me
your thoughts as someone who is Gen Z I
watched this video where it was this gen
Z guy being like welcome to a New York
micro apartment $2,000 a month for like
70 square feet it's a it's it's five 5
and 1 half ft wide and like and 10 ft
deep so we're talking like you know 55
Square F feet and it's got a sink no
bathroom nothing else a single window
and if you want to use the bathroom it's
shared in the hallway two grand $2,000
per month
and so I I I think what we're seeing now
the reason why Donald Trump is getting a
lot of gen Z support and he is several
polls have him up with Gen Z which is
crazy look if you're a boomer it's real
easy to be a boomer and have access to
wealth on average Boomers have more
access than genen Z does for obvious
reasons you're older you've got a
savings you got a retirement or
something so you're likely living in a
house or an apartment or condo or
something like that jenz is trying to
move into places and they're running up
against the wall they can't afford it at
the same time they can't afford it guess
what's happening in New York City
illegal immigrants are being given hotel
rooms they're giving they're given free
money free places to stay now imagine
this imagine you're 22 24 hey you are 24
you're fresh out of college you got a
degree like they told you to get you
can't find a job and you're standing
outside in W with your little you know
attache case holding your resumés and
there's an ilal immigrant buying free
food and going into their hotel room
with a bed a TV a bath bathroom and
security private security and you're
like maybe if I'm lucky I can get one of
those shoe box pods to live in you know
what's going to happen they're going to
be like I'm voting for Donald Trump yeah
it's the you will own nothing and be
happy mentality because when you get an
entire generation who simply cannot
afford on their salaries to even save up
money to then even invest in property
they're going to rent for the rest of
their lives and it's true I mean these
immigrants are getting everything handed
to them I mean now in New York free
healthcare uh in California you have
medical where 00,000 migrants were
approved to get free taxpayer dollar
paid Healthcare I mean these people are
walking across the border with
absolutely no consequences with what a
court date that's two years out phones
paid for by us and uh and they're
getting more amenities than your college
graduate who's 60 70 $100,000 in debt
and will never be able to pay that off
we got to do like a I don't know like a
Curb Your Enthusiasm style joke or
something about an illegal immigrant in
this nice hotel with a comfortable bed
and a TV and then the hardworking guy is
like living in the Pod and eating bugs
he hires him to clean his toilet or
something
right I mean they're living the American
dream more than Americans are yeah it's
really when you see it with your own
eyes is when things start to change like
I can imagine residents in New York
walking down 42nd Street to go to work
where they're get paid like 16 bucks an
hour and they have to step over homeless
people obviously and then you find out
that there's people that don't speak
English staying in these hotels like I
remember in LA in '08 um I had friends
that were illegal immigrants that were
working at the restaurant I was working
at and working in the environment and
they were getting put up in like $400 a
month hotels where I was paying 1,200 or
1300 a month for mine and I was just the
jealousy in me from that was like
rampant I could I had to check myself
I'm like no they're getting an
opportunity but if you saw that in Mass
I could imagine like what in the hell is
going on it shouldn't take one state
busing thousands of people to other
states so that way the other states feel
the pain of of of the of the migrants
that are coming in to get the rest of
the country to pay attention and it
definitely shouldn't take those measures
to have the federal government ignore
its its its job like the federal
government is supposed to take care of
the borders and it's preventing the
state from from trying to close the
borders that the that the feds refus to
take care of the fact that the that that
the house hasn't drawn up papers of of
Articles of impeachment for for
literally not doing your job the
president ignoring the border the the
the this is this this is the house
should absolutely have have drawn up
papers Absolut no but but I mean the
federal government is Rogue in it its
entirety the Supreme Court being like no
you can't defend your borders what the
federal government being like we're
going to facilitate human smuggling and
Congress which a republican Advantage
doing nothing to try and Corral the
corruption let me this story stop pay
just stop funding it Congress has the
control of the funding well they're
they're doing nothing let's pull this s
from the hill ladies and gentlemen the
escalation is here Texas Democrat calls
on Biden to seize control of Texas
National Guard rep Walkin Castro is
calling on President Biden to take
control of the Texas National Guard if
the state defies a Supreme Court ruling
uh which it did Governor Greg Abbott is
using the Texas National Guard to
obstruct and create chaos at the border
if Abbott is defying yesterday's Supreme
Court ruling pus needs to establish sole
Federal control of the Texas National
Guard now he can't by the way doesn't
work that way the governor has to sign
off on federalization basically saying
like Okay through me you can give orders
and we can unify in this
instance I I don't want to tell you guys
you have these people let me show you
this tweet this is Janai Nelson
president and direct Council of ldf
NAACP legal defense and educational fund
saying this is outright Defiance of a
supreme court order by a southern
governor who thinks he is above the law
federalism means anything it means Greg
Abbott must be held to account let me
let me let me make clear
Southern dig or and let me make clear
what we are seeing now is Greg Abbott
enforcing the law to the best of his
abilities walking cast and Democrats are
lying about what's going on saying it's
chaos yeah well he said that Greg abbt
is causing the chaos it is chaos at the
border they're trying to stem the chaos
the actions being taken to uphold
federal law and state law is chaos the
Biden Administration and Democrats are
actively destroying this country and I I
got to be honest guys like I don't know
I can't mince words on this one they are
quite literally destroying the country
this is not I don't how do I say this
they are engaged in a seditious
conspiracy to subvert the Constitution
and destroy the fabric of this country
that's not hyperbole when when when Ian
brings up his parents who are not super
politically engaged and watch MSNBC
saying this is getting crazy when I I
bring up Chicago and New York because
when you have major Democrat strongholds
in panic over the crisis that is
happening right now and the Biden
Administration with a smile on his face
says the border is not secure and then
tries to Dam further there is no
question we are watching a man pour
lighter fluid on the fabric of this
nation and set it a flame while we all
scream the outcome here if the feds do
make a move to try and seize control of
the National Guard or deploy federal
agents Texas to try and stop them guys
what do you call it when armed forces
under State jurisdiction engage in
active conflict with Federal forces call
it whatever you
want I don't know if if the if the
president I mean he's the
commander-in-chief of the Armed Forces I
don't know if the if the National Guard
of Texas would the guard of Texas would
it's not under his jurisdiction I don't
think well I mean the the feds can call
them up they called them up and sent
them overseas it's a question of where
are these Guardsmen from right are they
residents of Texas who enlisted in Texas
I'd imagine they'd have to be right yeah
but you but even still that like you
don't go to the same you you still go to
like Army wherever the Army does their
basic training that doesn't that doesn't
mean anything in in the in in 1861 you
had West Point graduates trained in New
York saying my home is Virginia yeah and
they said I will and that's I mean the
famous generals I will stand with my
state but I don't think that people
think like that anymore so I mean do you
think the 19-year-old guy whose mom
lives in I don't know Austin is going to
be like nah I'm going to go to war with
my with my neighbors and friends no idea
what your ear e the what what a kid's
going to do I there are people there are
people like I would have said something
different before January 6 last year
when the when the feds filled up DC with
you know troops for no reason the
question is are these Guardsmen from
Texas and connected through Community to
Texas if the answer is yes there is no
question if the feds make a move against
Texas and try to seize control of the
guard on average people will always just
defend their friends and their families
yeah you're talking about what what
people are likely to do I'm wondering
what the law actually says apparently
and not not I'm reading this from
findlaw.com that title 32 gives
Governors the authority over the guard
in their states but then they say that
title 10 says the president can mobilize
the guard and put it under Federal
Authority yes but under what
circumstances my understanding is the
governor has to sign off on it if that
if that's the case then if the governor
has to say yes then then that's the case
um but yeah I don't I don't know for
sure um well I mean I think
realistically the reason this country is
still alive is because states are
preeminent the federal government's an
afterthought like like we are United
States we we unite by choice the Civil
War completely changed all of
that yeah it did that's that like what
you're talking about is the way that the
the states thought of themselves prior
to the Civil War when the states still
thought that they could secede yeah like
they used to think before like Texas in
their Constitution before they joined in
their constitution I believe it says
we're reserving the right to leave
because Texas used to be its own country
so I think could seced theoretically so
allegedly I don't know that the federal
government would would allow it the feds
might still say no we settled this with
the with the Civil War according to the
federal government the Civil War settled
the the question as to whether or not
countries can seced so and no actually
you lets Grant wrote up exactly why they
cannot and I believe he's correct the
the so there are certainly uh uh he's
mostly correct he wrote this great
letter and he said basically the states
of the Union sacrificed blood and
treasure to admit these states to join
in and they owe a debt to declare that
they would separate while in debt is you
know I'm paraphrasing but you can read
the whole letter basically his point is
yo homie I paid a bunch of money for you
to come and and join this crew you can't
just bow out now you owe us and that
makes sense is that it I mean something
that effect is the argument being made
and so does that mean imp perpetuity
well that's a good point that's why I
say mostly correct mostly correct being
so long as you you you are in a Debt Pay
that debt back and we negotiate however
that is but I do believe that ultimately
it doesn't matter because uh ulysis
Grant also wrote you are you have the
right to secede but no if you if there
is a debt to be paid you will be at War
and if you lose you'll be ruled by your
uh by The Victors so his his point is
basically at any point any person any
any state could declare they will no
longer be part of the Union but be
prepared prepared to fight and if you
lose you are now under under our rule I
imagine that they there will be a there
would be a fight if uh Texas were to say
well we're going to just kick federals
troops out yeah it wouldn't be like
leaving uh the union it would be like yo
obviously fed Florida and Texas are
unified so if there was a union like
what's the union how many unions where
who was United exactly is it 49 of the
states decide to unify against this
stupid federal government that's gone
too far that then where's what's the
union the union is the people that are
unifying it's not doesn't it's not on
paper it's like what's really happening
right now I just I you know I just find
it fascinating how many people uh
scoffed at the idea of civil war and
then even after January 6 you still got
a lot of people say January 6 was not an
Insurrection but these Democrats who
claim it is still scoffed the idea of
civil war right now you have I'm I'm I'm
sorry my friends we quite literally have
the lowest degree possible but we do
have armed conflict between a State
National Guard and the federal
government now I want to be careful here
because I don't want people to assume
armed conflict implies people are
shoting at each other what this means is
both factions have
deployed armed personnel and they are in
conflict with each other meaning Texas
National Guard are defying Federal
mandate and pushing out uh uh uh federal
agents to take territory the feds want
that territory back the only only thing
that hasn't happened is they've not
decided to fight about it yet physically
but there are armed men in Conflict
right now trying to control certain
jurisdictions I mean this is a powder
kig it's it's
certainly far more significant than
January 6th was January 6th it was a
riot that got out of hand this is Joe
Biden is engaged in Insurrection this is
I mean
that's I I think it is definitive at
this point Joe Biden should be removed
from the bout in as many states as he
can for for engaging an insurrection
actively right now by subverting the
Constitution and engaging in a seditious
conspiracy of human smuggling in
defiance of even blue states to make any
argument that Trump engaged in
Insurrection and to then make the
argument that that Biden has not is
completely ridiculous and UNS serious
see I don't think they're actually going
the federal government is actually going
to go down to Texas and seize the
National Guard because I think they
would legitimately have a civil war at
hands because Texas would like not they
wouldn't allow that and so why would the
federal government especially in an
election year go down there and do
something because then the problem would
get 10 times worse and I think to your
point of you know Eric Adams and 50% of
the hotel rooms are taken up by illegal
immigrants and we have this huge crisis
in our country why would he continuously
make it worse I honestly think it's a
political play just to paint Texas and
Greg Abbott like the bad guys do
something why would they make it worse
so that Donald Trump can't win an
election in November M that's true the
purpose that so you know know we were
talking before the show Ian was saying
they they would not be able to win a
Civil War I mean it's ridiculous I'm
like they would because the wind
condition is not like one side climbs
the top of the hill and plants a flag
the win condition for people who hate
America is to destroy the fabric of the
country starting a civil war is the win
condition for these people so when I
hear people say like National divorce
I'm like that will be civil war there is
no circumstance where there is a
peaceful separation of States impossible
because of water rights because of
farming rights because of Highway access
because of weapon control because of
General natural resources which states
have access to I mean come on the North
Dakota Frack Fields would become an
economic Powerhouse and then you're
going to have someone in a different a
different state being like I'm the one
who paid for all of that and they're
going to say no we you're going to get
Conflict for sure if we do there will be
no Constitution anymore right in in the
Civil War in 1861 Abraham Lincoln
suspended habus Corp in a corridor
stretching from DC up to Pennsylvania
the reason being Maryland was a slave
state with massive Southern uh uh uh
sympathies so he had members of their
legislature arrested and created a
corridor where they could travel between
DC and Pa so the union could stay
unified with DC and they would arrest
anyone without charge or trial who in
any way bothered them and there's
actually one guy they did locked him up
for the duration of the war and he gave
him the middle finger and said f you
when the war ended they let him go and
then he just F you and they're like your
charges stand said f you and he he left
and then that was like they just let it
go it you can read about the story it
was crazy Abraham Lincoln when the war
started Constitution was gone yeah if
you were if you were speaking Pro
Confederacy speech you're locked up done
no question if a civil war were to break
out the I mean let me let me just tell
you do you guys think let me ask you a
question the Epstein Client
List let's say there's a person we know
that they're ultra wealthy individuals
and Powerful they're on The Client
List do you which would you think they
would prefer having their name published
in the press as to being a high-profile
billionaire pedophile who is working
with Epstein or Civil War breaking the
machine apart what do you think these
people would rather have happened oh
Civil War they they don't want to be
exposed yeah absolutely they don't want
accountability they don't want to get
caught they want to keep up their
operations keep up the crimes they're
committing and they'd rather the United
States burn and they would find out what
they're doing I mean that's what they
want to destabilize Western Civilization
as we know it and they want to destroy
the Constitution but that's all coming
from the wef they've been wanting to do
this for decades of just continuously
destabilize our country as we know it
take away our freedom slowly but shortly
and I mean even now gen Z they will
they're willing to do anything to make a
dollar and they have they don't even
have a care about politics or what's
going on in our country and so you
actually show them the amount of college
kids actually that I interview asking if
they even know about the Border crisis
or how many people are coming into our
country or that their taxpayers are
paying for it in whether it's in San
Diego California or Texas so many kids
have no idea because they don't watch
the news all they watch is brainwashing
on Tik Tok and they don't actually know
the crisis is going on you know a lot of
people have made the joke that
everything started to fall apart when
Epstein
died and there's a meme that around the
time Epstein dies you get the breakdown
of narrative control you get the
lockdowns you get I mean people start
losing their minds now I certainly don't
think that means that whatever Epstein
was doing was the the top of the
mountain in terms of this deep state or
I I I like the new phrase that we're
getting from the K Lake scenario people
back East what did he what did he say oh
that what a video yeah people back East
that guy resigned by the way he did he
did resign defitely talk about that but
I'm wondering if whatever it is
Epstein's involved in has scattered the
Cockroaches dude and that's and this is
why the narrative machine is breaking
because it used to be that high-profile
Millionaires and billionaires and
politicians were all partying and then
once abene gets caught they all say
every man for themselves yeah it feels
like abject Panic it does feel like that
like the Panic that I can't see but I
can sense that it's happening behind the
scenes because it's so quiet it's so
quiet about that epscene stuff too quiet
yeah I think so too I mean come on we
know powerful people on that list
they're going to be heads of Industry
they're going to be politicians they're
going to be world leaders it could be
Bill Clinton like Andrew like I've heard
that Bill Clinton literally flew with EP
a bunch of times probably got massages
from 15-year-olds God knows what else
they did uh I'm not know probably is the
right word but like that if it was Bill
if you found the Bill Clinton of all
people it's like the grossest underage
sex scandal on Earth and then you're
implicating people like Bill like what
in the what is that bro prince Andrew is
photograft with one of thece of England
yeah Prince of the of the United Kingdom
D I mean this is already that serious
think about how look man you look at you
you look at like the Emirates you look
at uh uh Saudi Arabia you look at the
the wealth that's down there you think
these people aren't also connected and
I'm not saying all of them I'm just
saying there are criminal corrupt people
with massive amounts of power probably
working with Epstein Epstein the whole
thing's broken whatever machine they had
running I'm not saying it was the
machine I'm not saying it was the Deep
state but too many people associated
with powerful industry and government
were involved in that and they're
scattering like cockroaches the light
got turned on and they rushed to the
corners of the room and now there's
nothing maintaining the facade
I mean I feel like the Epstein was was a
a an Intel asset and so I mean that's
kind of what would happen if or that's
what you would expect to happen if you
know if he actually did have you know
information on powerful people and stuff
like that and they were using it as
state secrets to to get compliance or
whatever they're going to try to squash
the list that Intel agencies don't want
anyone to know about what they're doing
ever like they just that's just
everything is as secret as they can get
I was picturing Tim you were talking
about EP getting off the plane with like
some dude I keep using Bill Clinton or
whoever it was some random guy and he's
like you like her a lot man yeah she
really likes you she's 15 bro we got you
and then like Epstein just seizes Alpha
control of Bill Clinton or whoever the
emotional control and and then they're
like what I can't even say he's got this
thing that I don't want him to have cuz
it's like can't even acknowledge that
he's got the thing I mean I imagine it's
like he's on the plane cuz they cuz the
reports are that the girls were on the
planes
and he invites someone like Clinton or
whoever it may be they're sitting on the
plane and then they say like hey meet
this uh hot young thing and then she
starts working on him and then once
she's done he says hey take a look at
the uh TV screen we got a movie we're
going to play and then he plays the
video of it happening and he goes by the
way she's 15 we got all of it man and
just like the the the balls that Epstein
had and then as soon as you say that
that politician that corporate officer
or whatever they start sweating
profusely like what do you mean it's
like don't worry relax I'm going to call
you and tell you what you what you need
to do when I need you to do it but
everything should be fine you work for
us now how many people are bought in
this country that we have no idea about
and I don't think we're ever going to
actually see the entire list because
once they're all implicated and you know
I think they should go to prison for the
rest of their lives uh it's going to
cause so much havoc in our country and
they don't want that list to come out
nobody does no like that's that's my
whole feeling on the whole Intel thing
like as long as it's connected to
intelligence you're going to have media
and governments doing everything they
can to shut it down and and what would
they rather have the list coming out
with their names on it or a civil war
Civil War plus I think they know the
list and let's not even say Civil War to
be honest would destabilization to the
point where there is no power able to
hold them accountable let me put it this
way if this country if Donald Trump
wins come November and then the list
does come out Bill Clinton's on it do
you think Democrats would believe or
care or even try to go after Clinton no
no they would they would lie about
what's going on they would say Donald
Trump fabricated a list to try and go
after his political Rivals oh dude
that's it they I mean this is why the
Boston Globe published that story where
they said Democrats wore gamed out what
would happen in 2020 and in the event
Donald Trump were to win they would
encourage west coast states to secede
from the union this literally happened
it's Boston Globe this is this this
story comes out in what like I think uh
uh uh mid 2020 this is where we are now
I want to talk about people back
East Gary lak's team slaps back at Jeff
DT's false claims he was blackmailed
into resigning over bribery tape and
says resigned Arizona Republican party
chair should apologize for his unethical
Behavior so oh whoa whoa we got to slow
down here Jeff dwit is the guy who was
caught on camera and we've called it
bribery
of of Carrie Lake I actually think it's
blackmail I think blackmail is a better
term is there an amount of
money I don't think he's trying to bribe
her when they both
explicitly are bringing up that when
when she says they're going to have me
murdered Carrie Lake says that in the
recording and he's like well if it's
true about the report with the cartel is
operating in all 50 states that doesn't
sound like bribery that's like a guy
came in and said be a shame if one of
these cartels people got you why don't
you take a job and just don't bother the
people back East that sounds like
blackmail Call It briber Whatever well
the latest news is that this guy
resigned he's claiming that the audio
has been altered in some way and car
lak's team came to him and said more
audio will be released unless you resign
now kry L's team is disputing this but I
got to tell you when you listen to the
audio my guy ain't nobody made you
become a scumbag who's going to go go to
k car Lake and offer her cash to drop
out of politics I was wondering is he
getting a cut is that why he was doing
that I was going to say he's a little
fish who is the big guy that's paying
him to talk to Cary Lake and say hey we
don't want you to run in the senate race
for next two years you know lay down
because there's no way out of his own
brain he said the People Back East who's
the people back East that are funding
this corruption not just in the state of
Arizona but there's more people that are
being bribed or blackmailed into running
exactly who is they they were they
didn't say numbers Carrie was like what
a billion that's not no I'm not going to
do it I'm like it can't be bought did
you guys play this video last night any
of it portions of it this isra it's 10
minutes long and it is edited I mean the
shocking thing is you know she says what
1 million 2 million it's not worth it
and I'm thinking like I know cuz right
the number is probably around 10 10
million I'm gone I'll be out the door no
I'm just kidding but uh uh the the the
question is they don't bring up in the
video who who they is right they say
they are saying this they said it's
powerful people back East so I have to
assume it's it's deep State it's
intelligence assets it's it's leaders of
industry it's people uh likely in DC
well even kry brought this up in the
video is like it's because they're
anti-trump and they the People Back East
they're going to put their money where
their mouth is I definitely think it's
the Deep State because they're going to
do anything to get the people that are
backing Trump and I mean car lake is one
of the biggest people in the country who
is backing Trump and who has been
unapologetically on that train so I
think it all goes back to this upcoming
election not even her Senate rise the
term deep state in this context I mean
when I think of the deep state I'm
specific in thinking about like
bureaucracy so I'm think of actual
government agencies so you're you're
whether whether it be the EPA or it be
uh you know DEA or whatever it is
justice department whatever I'm thinking
of some kind of government
agency I don't know where they're going
to come up with money to bribe her out
of an actual government agency I think
that it's more more likely that it would
be like someone that sends money to S to
PX like a a wealthy investor something
like that than than actually you know an
actual person in the government So when
you say de deep State I think of actual
Bure bureaucracy that's actually in the
government as opposed to which of these
high level donors also murder
people that's why deep State fits
better powerful uh interests uh special
interests massive coffers and the means
and will to assassinate well she the
assassination when they were like I
don't think they're going to do that and
the and the guy what's his name Adams
McAdams the guys Jeff dit Jeff dit was
like yeah I don't think they're going to
do that they
implying assassinate Cary Lake they they
would no they in the very beginning they
talked about it and then there was a
cartel thing but then about 6 minutes in
they talked about the People Back East
doing it and they're both like no I
don't think they would do that more
money guys at the end of the video says
if paraphrasing if I go public my car I
will put my key in my car yeah yeah he
did say that she says they're going to
have me murdered and he said well if
it's true about the cartel operating in
all 50 states you know then at the end
she says go public he goes no no no no
no no then I turn my key in my car and
well if he said cartel he talking about
is he talking about drug cartel was was
he using the the phrase more uh
Ambiguously talking about the drug
cartel yeah they said that in the very
beginning was out of context you missed
the what they were talking about but
they said the cartel is operating in all
50 states or something like that and I
it just assumes that he's talking about
the Mexican drug cartels with this video
being released like I'm at the point now
where anybody can come to me with any
conspiracy conspiracy theory and I'm
going be like well I believe you over
the government or the Press like all the
stuff they kept saying was a lie
remember when Epstein was a conspiracy
theory yeah and then Amy robach over at
ABC has that video leaked where she's
like I had it I had it Mike cernovich
files this paperwork with Mark randazza
Miami I think it's what the Miami Herold
was that or who was it was Mii Herold
who got involved or was it times I'm not
sure might have been the herald I'm sure
you a fact check but more journalists
get involved we get these documents
released and then this forces the hand
for them to go after Epstein and all of
a sudden it wasn't a conspiracy theory
anymore Alex Jones was not was not crazy
it was just well of course then Epstein
dies while in jail with the cameras
failing and the guards falling asleep I
think it was Julie K brown with uh with
the Miami Herold yeah the heral okay
that that's what I've come to see is
like all this dirty dark potential is
like I used to just kind of wash it out
and be like no no no that's video game
stuff that's movie villain stuff that's
not real stuff and now like oh if it can
be done there's a likelihood that it is
being done bro I used to I used to think
very much the same way that life is much
more boring than people realize and I
still think that's true to a degree but
holy crap Carrie Lake published audio of
a guy saying people back East want to
pay you money to drop out of the race
yeah just to pause her campaign pause
for well yeah that's a drop out pause
for a couple years pause all government
car will explode if he goes public is
there anyone else that's that's running
against her or who is running against
her that's that's on the conservative
side know she have someone that she's
because I imagine if they want her to
drop out they would want her to drop out
or to pause her campaign because they
would they have someone that they would
prefer to be in the
position if it were if it were a
conservative or if it were someone think
at this point all the Republicans should
drop out of the primary a
2024 yeah it's the Republican primary
for US Senate so you've got Christopher
Bersa unofficially withdrew Leonard fure
Carrie Lake Mark Lamb Connie Moreno
Elizabeth Ray Robert Walker alen white
Brian Wright I think they should all
drop out I like Mark Lamb you what I
like Mark Lamb I think they should all
drop out all of them but Carrie yep yeah
Carrie is massively popular she's
National
popular and the concern now
is look I I'll put it this way I don't
live in Arizona take it with a grain of
salt you don't got to take my advice any
one of these people I'm not going to get
mad at them if they don't drop out but
my view is I don't trust anyone who
stays
in that the the chair of the Republican
party you know he's in communication
with these people who are running did he
go to any of these other candidates and
offer them a bribe to drop out
definitely not I would I would assume no
it's Carrie Lake she's MAA she's
they want Trump to lose and you know
that pause does not mean pause she drops
out for 2 years she's gone oh yeah and
then they' Expos that they bribed her
after the fact and then she'd tarnish
her name with that absolutely they'd
publish the bribe and say look Carri
Lake took money to drop out she's been
corrupt the whole time now I look at
these other people who are running and
I'm like which one of them is in cahoots
with with thewit because DT's going to
carry L saying drop out the inverse is
happening he's going to one of these
guys and being like how much can we give
you that does suck that these people
would even be remotely implicated cuz a
lot of these people are probably just
honestly trying to trying to run and
then they got all this malfeasance at
the top yep and then they're part of
this dirty system but hey that's
politics that's politics man and we're
in the United States which is apparently
the least worst but it's probably not
the least worst cuz the power that you
can gain if you get control of that
system it's all back scratching I
scratch your back you scratch mine
that's what even Carrie was talking
about like he she's the only one that
will say no because there are too many
politicians whether it's federal
government or state governments that are
being paid off actively by whether it's
the GOP by democrats by Deep State there
are too many people corrupt people in
our government systems and they're being
paid on they're just being paid by super
packs or by by donors to get in there
which is technically a legal thing so
you wouldn't even call them being paid
off but it's like then they' be holding
to the where they their money oh it's
just so have you guys uh bought any
emergency
food D I mean
listen we knew 2024 was going to be wild
it's 2023 we're like it's going to get
crazy it's the first month in and there
are armed National
Guardsmen declare and the governor of
Texas declaring Supremacy over the
border with the federal government
trying to open the border and we have
again still the first month in Carrie
Lake releasing audio of an attempt to
bribe her n blackmail her into dropping
out with the fear of death on the line
from a guy who they will kill him if
this if this information goes public wow
I didn't know it was going to kick off
this quick I was like maybe by the time
springtime's coming around things are
getting warmer we're going to get crazy
riots and there's going to be weird
stories about you know ptes or
something man yo March 5ifth is going to
be a crazy day it it was Trump getting
in and being like everyone there's a
deep State look under the covers this is
what it looks like and uh everyone lost
their and but then it's having
Biden in office which is so bad like
it's not that I hate the guy it's that
he's mentally incompetent that he's aged
so rapidly in the last four years and
like the vacancy is is why a lot of this
junk is is I don't think it matters so I
mean Obama wouldn't be so stupidly
challenging Texas as Authority in Texas
like that's that's a man do you think
Biden's really up to it though because I
think there's other people behind the
scenes that are they're the ones that
are telling hey Abbot you guys were
going to come and Seize Your National
Guard and we're going to open up the
border and you guys are the going to
have to pay for the buses and the
flights I mean I'm in Sky Harbor just in
Phoenix every single week and I see
dozens if not hundreds of illegal
immigrants getting on airplanes every
single day I talk to the uh TSA agents
all the time and it's not stopping
whether it's Texas or Arizona I'll tell
you what scares me the most it's not
actually the Border it's not uh Biden
and his fumbling bumbling speech what
scares me the most is that when Biden
says TR sh of pressure The Crowd Goes
yay oh man Luke posted this Lukowski
Biden goes because when you mess with
r you got you got can't and The Crowd
Goes screaming cheering I'm like the
emperor has no clothes book was written
about quite literally said no words and
the crowd was cheering and uproar
remember this is a I'm listen this is a
crowd where someone I mean look people
talk about the fervor of Nazis and how
they screamed and cheered for Hitler
Hitler was speaking to them yeah at
least he was saying words what he was
saying he was saying things they were
terrible but they're terrible things but
the thing is the opposition could
discern their plans Joe Biden stands up
and
goes and then hands everybody a club and
they go woo and then they start marching
around and you're like what are they
doing everyone in the back looks like a
deranged feminist you know Millennial
white woman who's just so unhappy with
their lives I I I I have to assume it's
all like AI generated video it's this
there's a book called The Emperor wears
no clothes where and I have never read
the book but I know the premise is that
the emperor they' come out and I don't
know if it's China or whatever they'd
March around and the emperor would be
naked but they'd be like look at the
beautiful outfit that the emperor has on
isn't it beautiful everyone look the
emperor is wearing a beautiful outfit
isn't it beautiful and everyone would be
like yes yes beautiful outfit and then
eventually one kid little kid was like
Emperor's not wearing any clothes and
everyone's
like and it's this moment of cognitive
dissonance where like youthful innocence
overrides this corrupt I don't know what
you would call it stupidity or can you
show your parents the video of him the
recent one where he goes you and the
crowd starts cheering yeah I got to find
it and then but don't show them any
commentary on it just play the video for
them ask them what they think and then
whatever they end up saying ask them
again why do you think the crowd is
cheering despite not knowing what Biden
said yeah they're cheering for the
regime that's the terrifying part
they're they're cheer that that shows
you Biden could literally call for the
extermination of a group of people and
they would cheer for it they got an
interesting perspective some of these
older people because they saw Biden in
the ' 80s '90s
2000s yeah they they so they they still
see like his youth in him when they look
at him I just see what I see which is
right straightforward I mean I I got
introduced to the guy in 2008 thought he
was a scumbag I don't know why Obama
picked him probably was he was chosen
for Obama because they needed some dark
money in there my old man they need my
old man to get when I look at him now I
look at like a vacant pale thin wispy
ancient and it's it's not in a good way
like I I I see this dilapidated uh
nonsense but I think a lot of people are
still they still see that Joe from 2006
that old smile and a wink gonna write
that crime Bill and plagiarize my
presidential campaign every like I don't
know how that got swept under the rug
that he's a plagiarist too it's the
worst thing drop out of 1988 he dropped
out of the presidential campaign cuz he
got caught plagiarizing his Camp
numerous
times let me just stress this again for
you guys right now though the Border
stuff is scary the the People Back East
man that's a quote we got to keep the
people back that's a scary quote who are
they yeah the fact that large crowds
will cheer for Biden with Biden not
saying words is much more terrifying
because this means these people could be
handed weapons and they'll just scream
and cheer for anything Biden could say
something abhorent and they would scream
and cheer for it at least when Donald
Trump says lock her up people chant back
lock her up with Joe Biden go and
they're like yay I did get a horrible
vision of the president ordering people
to turn on American citizens like
whoever an outgroup of some sort whether
you call it the the the Nazis the the
magga Republicans the the black people
the white people you pick a group and
and then but in my mind I visualized
people cheering it on being like
literally happening that's notzi Germany
like that's happening now bro it's been
happening for like a year or longer it
literally happened when Hillary Clinton
said uh the basket of deplorables people
cheered for that but but worse than that
they've been calling Trump supporters
maggots yeah for for years now and Joe
Biden says his his first campaign
commercial was they are your enemy and
Must Be Stopped I see the cheering like
uh for the rhetoric but I was
visualizing like a guy on the street
getting clubbed and other people getting
on the news and people being like yeah
get and like don't let the country come
to that don't become that guy bro that's
like that's like TV in 2020 I was seeing
all that happening already I feel I feel
like it's it's been going on all the
stuff that you're you're you're worried
about possibly happening in the future
happened in the past happened in 2020
people were getting beat if it happened
in Nazi Germany we should take a message
we should take a Learning
lesson say that exact same thing since
like
2015 when Milo was getting punched in
the face that like you don't you can't
sit there and just say oh punch a Nazi
it's okay we need to calm these things
down all of that was the start of what
we're seeing now that was almost 10
years ago and then you have Chris re G
who made a song punch a Nazi which was a
satirical version of Paparazzi by Lady
Gaga pointing out how these people are
going around saying that you that
encourage people to engage in violence
against anyone they disagree with and
the threats of of violence were so
extreme Chris Reagan took the video down
a couple years later and then totally
just disappeared off the face of the
earth I I think he still does videos of
some sort but man that he runs he run he
ran in panic he got rid of it yeah but
he got rid of it that's crazy this is
not something that's coming in the
future
this is not like the government being
against a group of of Americans the IRS
has all was used to Target Americans in
like
2012 12 years ago this is not someday
this is coming this is happening right
now the I know that it's Donald Trump
but like they're they're
fabricating and and doing everything
they can to circumvent due process to
just slap this guy with punishments is I
feel like there is some scapegoating
happening from the top rhetorically but
people are strong mentally to not fall
for it I just want to encourage people
to continue to not fall for it and don't
scapegoat other groups of people they
have not they have not not fallen for it
they have fallen hookline and sinker for
it I know people that have not Fallen
forth that I would have thought have
there are some people that have not of
course but I think that the the reason
that we talk about things like people
kind of realize that things are bad when
they saw like what their kids were
seeing in schools during covid or when
they saw the way that the government uh
was behaving during Co all of that stuff
had been there were people warning about
that stuff for at least a decade prior
at least 10 years before all of that
stuff happened there were people saying
hey this is happening this is happening
some people were saying it 20 years
earlier like Alex Jones as as much as
people hate to admit it like Alex Jones
was was predicting some of the some of
the crazy remember when he predicted 911
yeah you know he was 20 years ago in
July of 2001 Alex Jones there's like a
famous recording of Jones you can watch
it where he's like they're going to be
targeting the World Trade Centers and
other places with Terr attacks and and
then he's and he talks for a little bit
then he mentions Obama I'm sorry Obama
Osama Bin Laden will be the main
scapegoat they've used him before blah
blah blah and it's just like you can
watch his videos in May of 2001 he was
talking about it five or six months
before stuff is not coming stuff is here
that Americans have not noticed because
it is not they have not targeted enough
Americans that
to the point where the the left leaning
kind of bad liberals Democrats that
should be more liberal than they are um
until those people start seeing it until
they start their friends start paying
for it until the laptop class starts pay
for it there will be no changes that's
why they moving these these illegal
immigrants to the cities is is crude as
it is I think is the most effective eye
opening because it forces you to look at
it it forces you to be be Holden to it
it's like it's like what Phil is saying
about the laptop class it's like if if
your daily life is so comfortable using
one of these guys and you have dopamine
feed from you know your TV Etc whatever
you're watching on TV and you're
comfortable like Phil always mentions
like people that are in like in a
comfortable situation don't Revolt
because they're just like their everyday
life is so is is so cushy there's no
reason there's like well what's what's
so bad about this happening it doesn't
affect me so like it you're like you
said it's crude but it's the only way to
make people experience it otherwise
they're not going to it's never going to
be a thing in their life ever it that is
Gen Z in a nutshell though because
every single on a college cus first of
they go to an indoctrination camp
they're learning everything that the
establish wants them to learn and then
they go on their phones for the rest of
the day and they're just sucked in and
living this mundane life doing
absolutely nothing paring and they're
just rotting like literally Jen's brains
are rotting especially in college
campuses and nothing is going to solve
it until we continue to press and make
people wake up I mean the whole Biden
Gaff thing that happened was at his
restore row rally where you see just
dozens of these lenal jenzy women that
are chanting for pro-choice and you know
therefore legal genocide of you know
babies being aborted in our country
which is absurd but that those are the
kind of issues that these women are
grasping on to and supporting Biden for
and same thing with the technology I
think they're Pro transhumanism you know
gen Z is trending in the direction of
the more crazy the better I I mean I
talked to kids all the time that have
read The Communist Manifesto and they
endorse Carl Marx and they love social
on College cuses I mean I've had fascist
yell fascist in my face and it happens
on every single campus across the
country and I think it's only getting
worse until we continue I mean I know
turning points you know we're actually
out there talking to kids but we're
going to need more of it because these
kids need to reverse the brainwashing
that they've been going through for
years yeah the it's like you want to
wake people up to horror without putting
them through horror the horror of like
scapegoating your government
scapegoating a class of person that that
we have it on camera Hitler doing that
to the Jews and the gypsies but
particularly the Jews so we have a
evidence like don't ever do that ever
again but how do you how do you get
people to realize that the Maga
Republican thing is is a scapegoat
attempt to get them to wake up to like
don't ever do that again how do you make
him do it again you just m you just say
like oh well you blame the people for
doing exactly what you're doing here
here here's here's here's the challenge
I
see there are very powerful people who
are involved with abstein level stuff
and it's periphery who don't want to be
exposed and I think it's probably Than
People realize so I think it was Bill
Maher who was doing his Club random is
that the name of his show yeah and he
said Jimmy Kimmel is the last person who
would be on on this list it's a it's
laughable he's a regular guy oh Jimmy
kimm such a nice guy why was Bill Mar
lying why why would Bill Mah lie was
Bill Maher on the list is Bill Maher on
the related to this is he involved in
this stuff big Hollywood guy bill marah
has been single for a long time uh Jimmy
Kimmel is Friends W with Epstein's
personal chef
and they've reportedly been in business
together in varing capacities so why
would Jimmy Kimmel's name appear on the
list or in in lists related to those in
the in the in the circle of Epstein
because he was in cahoots with Epstein's
Chef that's one degree of separation
we're talking about Kevin Bacon we're
talking about a like my friend literally
works for the guy we hang out all the
time he's got a restaurant I I I go to
when you get people like Bill Maher who
are trying to cover up and trying to
downplay the severity of what's going on
it makes me it makes me feel like the
the sphere of corruption in related to
uh intelligence assets EP Etc the Deep
state is much wider than people realize
and if it's not the case that Bill Maher
has something to hide he's so stupid he
is pushing people in the wrong direction
causing damage and so what I see from
this is how do we convince the people
the Maga Republican thing is a big lie
it's tough because the Maga Republican
thing this is the princip faction
calling out those who are connected to
Epstein in child trafficking and Jimmy
Kimmel is in that sphere of influence
but he's got powerful allies assets
resources and money that will use the
med the media to lie to people because
he does not want to be involved he
doesn't not he does not want to like he
does not want people coming out being
like did you know that he was he was
really good friends with Epstein's Chef
that's bad for him so you get powerful
interest interests being like you know
what ends up happening is someone says
yeah if I talk bad about him I bring
this up I can't on his show and that's
that that is a it is it is not just that
people are on the Epstein list it's that
there may be a guy who knows who is on
the list and thinks yeah but if I call
him out he won't buy my product anymore
that sphere of influence is massive
absolutely massive they're going to do
everything in their power to keep that
covered up in every capacity I maybe we
can try and make some some Nuance on the
Epstein stuff because like most people
that were connected with Epstein had
know they didn't have sex with underage
women I would imagine like Frank
Reynolds and it's always fny he was just
there for the snorkeling yeah exactly he
know taking the SES people a lot of
people probably just did business with
Epstein because he was a big businessman
and loved to make connections but never
got to the level of going on the plane
with them or they knew somebody that
knew Epstein and like if they're afraid
of acknowledging the thing then they're
going to be hiding the people as well
that did the nasty so we we we should
maybe go ease off on some of the people
that were connected to it uh to try and
find the darkest well shout out to the
It's Always Sunny team because their
latest season Frank Reynolds is like I
went to the island and they're like what
and he's like I didn't know anything
about it I was there for the snorkeling
but because it's absurd like how could
you have gone there and not known what
was going on the Island's not that big I
bet it was like some people were having
dinner while parties while like six of
the dudes went into back rooms and those
are the guys they got on that that clip
bro the girls were on the plane there's
no way if anybody was on a plane getting
to the island they didn't know about the
child trafficking no way if if you know
you just had a one single meeting behind
closed doors with abstein or you saw him
at a party cross and shook hands that's
one thing like photograph with him but
if you were on the plane I don't think
there was there's no doubt in my mind
that they knew about this thing is if I
met Epstein and I went to a restaurant
and I sat down and it was Epstein and
some girl that looked like 16 and he's
like she's a model I wouldn't question
it I would have been like okay dude a
lot of models are that age exactly which
is crazy and gilane would specifically
look for young models like they had a
modeling agent let me let me jump to the
story from The Epic Times
main secretary says voters May cast
bouts for Trump without knowing if it
will count I mean that's it right there
the the main superior court ordered that
the secretary of state has to wait for
the Supreme Court to respond as to
whether or not Trump can be removed
before taking him off so she says okay
then people may vote for him and if the
Supreme Court says he can be removed
their votes are disqualified despite
having already been cast they're not
just talking about removing Trump from
the ballot anymore they are talking
about retroactively removing votes for
him now understand what this means there
are many states Colorado whatever
they've lost it's like we want to remove
Trump no you can't do that if the
Supreme Court does rule that is up to
the states to decide maybe scotus
doesn't come out and say Trump can be
removed they say narrow ruling it is up
to the states to determine their
elections have a nice day Maine
instantly then says all Trump votes are
here by disqualified Colorado says all
Trump votes are here by disqualified and
they can just do it they are going to
retroactively remove Trump from the
election but then the Florida would
would remove Biden Texas would remove
Biden and that would be pointless like
it would just Supreme Court can't allow
that it would be pointless in that it
would create pointless Federal we
wouldn't have a federation anymore
correct the Supreme Court kind of has no
choice but to uphold the constitution on
this and the Constitution says State
legislatur decide how their elections
are run y maybe the state congress is
not
State not Governor they already allowed
that to happen this past how things run
and if they run are different stories
you can't remove candidates and say that
that's actually happening legit that's
not a legitimate bro they're protecting
democracy bro it's I
mean I don't know what they can or can't
do because there's a lot of stuff that I
would have said they can't do that
they've already done yeah you can't
infringe the right to keep and bear arms
right no right man that one's been
infringed quite a bit a lot DC it's it's
funny it's Federal jurisdiction of all
places to be Holden to be holding to the
Constitution and you can't have guns
there yeah it's ridiculous it's there is
the Constitution is just a piece of
paper as long as people don't believe in
it and if the people don't actually want
to hold Joe Biden accountable for
allowing the kind of illegal immigration
that that he's
allowed then what's going to happen is
Governor Abbot will stand up to the
federal government as long as he thinks
he can the federal government might
actually do something maybe there will
be violence and if the people don't
support the idea that the that Texas was
right the American people are not going
to say they're going to say no you were
wrong and blah BL blah but if the mo if
the majority of people say Texas is
right it doesn't matter what the feds
think because most people are going in
the court of public opinion that's
what's actually going to at the end of
the day matter the most but I don't
think that most people feel that way I
think most people are going to side with
the government because most people are
stupid say the government what do you
mean the tax federal government most
people don't even know what the
Constitution says let alone what the
laws are of what the Supreme Court can
and can't do that's the problem they
have no idea what is going on I mean Jen
Z I literally filmed a video of you know
what is the first what are the five
rights protected in the First Amendment
and they you they cannot tell you they
couldn't tell me what the Second
Amendment Third Amendment any of the
amendments were how many uh amendments
were in the Bill of Rights and that they
want to change the Constitution because
it's a living and breathing Constitution
so when it comes to an issue like this
in Maine you no it's not a living and
breathing Constitution at all but the
problem of this in Maine is Americans
will not bat their eye and they will
think that this is legal and that the
federal government can do whatever they
want and sure you know Trump's off the
ballot what happens then like people
will fall for it and they will think
it's legal and okay when it's not that
sounds very blackpilled are you do you
find yourself without hope no because I
think there is hope I I think there is
if people continue to press in and have
conversations and you know rebuke this
kind of stuff because you know if Maine
does this I to your point I think Texas
should be like all right we're removing
Biden and same with Florida and Fight
Fire with Fire so you do a lot of men
men on the street stuff right yeah and
so I'm asking I want to ask particularly
about when you when you ask people about
um um when they say they are uh voting
for man I'm kind my TR of thought here
it was about particular men men Tre
stuff here I let see if I can remember
pardon me like totally derailed right
there um but I totally forgot what I was
going to say pardon me guys my bad
that's it that's right I love you well
we're just everyone's going to remain
totally silent for the next several
minutes sear figure out I will say
though about man on the street stuff is
like I I am I kid you not I've had
students tell me they want to take away
the Second Amendment entirely that US
citizens have no right to have an AR and
I'm like well what is that assault rifle
it's not an assault rifle it's an for
ArmaLite for everyone who doesn't know
that and and that's the craziest part oh
what are the five rights protected in
the First Amendment they can't even tell
me it's speech assembly petition relig
they have no idea the rights that they
have and that what we're doing is to
protect their rights and they would do
anything to get rid of them well my
response is you know if I talk to some
that said I want to get rid of Second
Amendment I'll be like okay here's my
idea you you want to live that way deal
so you don't get a First Amendment you
don't get a second amendment and then I
want to live my way so I do get it all
right why not all right solution solved
problem solved you can live however you
want to live go live that way it's uh
real important that we teach kids about
the Constitution that's like
indoctrinating uh important they have
stopped doing that though that's so
shocking like that's the primary school
systems like primary function I would
think failed make people understand the
way the government works AB that is not
math in that collegate history classes
are focusing now more on critical race
Theory having race based history than
they are US History same thing you know
go back in middle school government
classes they're not teaching the basics
of our government anymore
most people don't know that the federal
government is not or that our government
is not a direct democracy most most
people don't know actually like it's as
basic as this most people assume that
they're not
free what I mean is most people assume
that they have to ask for permission to
do
things that's the general Assumption of
the average American and and when when
someone something they don't like the
first thing they say is that can't be
legal he can't be allowed to do that you
hear it constantly constantly constantly
I used to see this word permit on street
signs when I was like nine and six I'd
see like doing this is permitted I'm
like well what does that word mean I'm
not allowed to do it cuz why would I
need a sign to tell me I'm allowed to do
something allow to do it how that's how
badly people understand or how poorly
people understand uh the the very
fundamental basics of American society
you are free that means you don't have
to ask permission to do and they
don't even get that like straight up the
gut instinct from most people is not
that they're free it's that they got to
ask someone if they can they're looking
for
permission so if you're starting with
people don't even understand that
they're free then that means that the
rights that are protected in the
Constitution they don't conceptualize
themselves as all already having they
don't believe they have the right to
free to to free expression they believe
that the government gives it to them
they believe they have to have
permission that is a fundamental
misunderstanding of what it means to be
an American and it is intentional that
people see things this way and the
evidence is in the
results I get like the idea that yeah
you can say God gave us our rights I get
it but like if you don't have guns and a
forc forcible strong border to keep out
idiots that are going to come enslave
you you don't have your rights so you
need to protect your rights with ar
Force of Arms but the concept that you
always had them anyway is kind of like a
tongue and cheek Ben Franklin thing I
get it you do have them it's just they
can be infringed so absolutely you need
vigilance and strength to to defend your
rights the Constitution exists because
the founding fathers knew your
inalienable god-given rights could be
infringed upon and so they said okay
government can't do this funny thing is
it's a piece of paper and you know
Michael malice points out that uh it's
it's it's effectively meaningless people
get mad about it but the reality
is we didn't have free speech the way we
know it today 50 years ago you couldn't
swear it was an obscenity you can get
arrested for swearing George Carlin went
got arrested for a comedy routine where
he said swear words and so I mean that
was effectively a hate speech law this
is why call the left reactionary woke is
reactionary they like to say the right
is reactionary what reactionary refers
to is uh the French Revolution you had
the the left and the right the
reactionaries were people who didn't
want the fall of the monarchy they were
you know I guess traditionalists
right-wing so reactionary means
typically it typically refers to people
who want things to go back to the way
they were this is what the left is they
want race-based law pre Civil Rights era
they want obscenity laws pre- free
speech they want us to go back in time
to the 1940s 1950s back to the way
things used to be except of course for
like you know women in the workplace
that you know it's not absolute but
they're absolutely reactionaries that
pertains to race and uh uh you know and
and and other policies like this so is
that like we have a new world order in
this internet-based economy and that
we're changing into whatever we want it
to be which is could be an American
Republic Bas Global Republic basically
where we have like localized governments
and but then there there there's
reaction to it which is like no no no
make sure it stays communist and take
away rights we need to make it more
amenable to corporate governance we need
to make sure that you don't step out of
line with your corporate they don't want
decentralization they want
centralization you know that that guy uh
noal what's his name Noah Harari that's
youval Noah Harari I just heard a speech
that he was doing um I guess from Davos
or whatever um and he's saying things
like you know that we don't actually
have the right to we don't we don't have
any any rights at all they're all just
fictions and everything essentially that
Society does is a fiction it's all a
game that we essentially agree to play
that's what Society basically is we all
agree to play by kind of the same rules
and his argument that there are no
actual rights that
essentially there's nothing that you
have a right to at all uh it it actually
is true as you know rights are just
Concepts that we create so if you don't
have any rights that are natural that's
what the government is for is to protect
individuals if it's not doing that then
it has no there's no ve there's no value
in having the government you know so it
doesn't matter if you if you want to
have a a um an international order or if
you want to have the I'm I'm totally
spacing on where my point was I get it
he did get it man it happens he did it
to me if he's saying that we're just
coffee today we're just playing a game
that Society is just a game of where
we're all kind of accepting this then I
I would counter with what when an armed
gunman walks into a room and guns down
six people were they all playing that
game no we need rights to protect our
ability to defend against that but the
the rights are the the thing that we do
create in order to protect against that
the rights are a are there a social
construct the game
no no against against a re the real
death that happens when someone comes in
and decides to not play the game because
the game is actually we get along we we
all you know manage to live together
without killing each other without
resorting to violence that's the game
that's what Society is they talk a lot
about civil Authority at the world
economic forum and the world is that's
half of the dime like the other side is
very gruesome and you need to protect
yourself that's these World economic
Forum dudes man we used to have shared
morality mhm it was it was believed that
we all recognized certain things were
right and certain things were wrong most
people did now you have the woke with no
moral framework at all I mean this is it
uh Prager refers it what what does he
call it cut stem or what is it I always
forget this cut stem politics or
whatever that a flower is beautiful you
cut it from its root you can hold it in
the air and it looks beautiful then
eventually it dies MH and what we are
dealing with right now is the far-left
ultr progressivists have been detached
from their for so long they are
withering yeah man there's this there's
this like I want to I want to impose
like morality on these people but until
you experience it and learn it for
yourself because I I learn from like
soldiers I watch interviews with
soldiers that and it's like whether
you're watching a guy bleed out and die
whether he's your on your side or the
enemy side you're still watching this
human bleed out and die we have rules of
law of War to protect against melting
human skin off with chemical War weapons
technically until you witness it and
then you realize why we have those rules
what does that rule mean you don't want
someone to spend 20 hours melting
screaming like you prefer not to so we
we so by all means enter a war where you
say we're going to fight by the rules
and the other side says I will do
anything in my power to destroy you and
guess who wins hopefully the whole world
unifies against that idiot that will do
anything toe create some sort of
Civility but I think we've already seen
that in the US I mean the left has lost
their morality basis entirely like you
know they're okay with killing children
in the womb they're okay with calling
out Republicans and hating our election
system and changing the Constitution so
where does their morality lie if it's
not more like they are the immoral and
so how do you teach somebody something
is immoral I don't think that personally
that they actually are are concerned
with morality I think that they're
concerned with you know trying to undo
the liberal order that we that the
United States has they're concerned with
power yeah the they wol the yeah the
point isn't you know I I've talked about
like my my opinion is that that they are
not they don't believe in the
enlightenment they believe that like you
can speak things into existence that's
why they refuse to you know that's why
they say oh if you call a transwoman a
woman she's actually a woman or if if
you call a trans man a man they're
actually a man they believe that words
have power they don't believe that you
can actually come in contact with
reality because everybody's reality is
different and stuff and that's really
for
to the foundation ideas that that
liberalism is based on you know the idea
that you can come into contct with with
reality is the foundation for what is a
reasonable person and the idea of a
reasonable person is all over our law
you look if you look at the way that
laws are written they constantly say
what a reasonable person would say or
that you come to a reasonable there's no
reasonable people anymore yeah if you if
you can't agree on what a man or a woman
is if you got Supreme Court justices
that refuse to a to to say what a woman
is that that will say I don't know what
a woman is or I can't Define a woman
then you can't expect that person to be
able to say what a reasonable person
would think and that literally this is
this is serious stuff this is actually
tearing at the foundations of all of our
laws of all of the structure of our
whole society the entire thing so when
you're talking about man people lack of
Morality In the government in the
federal momentum at the moment and that
you're you were suggesting that their
their focus is untethering or unwinding
the liberal economic order to create
this new world what I I see is the way
we unwind it is the New World Order so
if we use corruptive adaptivity if we're
willing to stomp out political opponents
unethically illegally to get this thing
that's what the new thing is going to be
the method is the is the meaning there
the the ends do not justify the means
because you never meet the ends the
far-left makes this argument that the
ends justify the means they say there's
an evil dictator in charge so we must do
everything by any means necessary to
stop him congratulations how do you now
defend your glorious new Revolution by
any means necessary of course great
you're you're the dictator that that
that's literally the theme of will of
the people the song that we released
three years ago these people will claim
they're fighting for justice and so
their tactics are Justified their
diversity of tactics but don't worry
when we take over we're going to put in
a bunch of reforms to prevent the
brutality then once they take over they
say well yeah but we didn't mean for the
fascists they're fascists we're we're
the so the way Venezuela views it the
revolution's never ended the fascist
forces have always been trying to take
back and they are in desperate need of
defense of the Revolution that's why
they have to arrest people and lock them
up the revolution is always unending
it's the logic of Herbert Mar Hughes you
have to shut down fascists you can't let
them talk you have to you have to shut
them down at the level of cons exception
of fascist ideas you have to to take
control of the language so that way you
cannot form fascist arguments well
that's gone Haywire with the Federal
Reserve getting formed obviously we are
living in a fascist system what about
communist because people are are saying
lately like did the McCarthy era not go
far enough McCarthy area didn't McCarthy
did not go far enough I understand not
shutting down the concept of Communism
you need to understand it to watch out
for it to defeat it and circumvent it
you need to know what it is but which is
why we have redw washed schools like you
don't hear about communism you don't
hear about the horrors of Communism
nearly as much as you should you there
should there has been significantly more
death due to communism because it was a
a system tried in so many different
places and has had has had a much longer
time that it was tried but as a system
it caused More Death than Nazism because
Nazism was you know everybody ganged up
on Nazism to to stamp the Nazis out and
yet you hear more about Nazism
everyone's aware of of the 6 million
Jews and however many uh gypsies were
killed and all the all the the people
that died in the in the death camps in
in Nazi Germany very and people are
aware that there were Googs in in Soviet
Russia and they're aware that there was
death in China coming to China but they
don't know how bad and they don't know
about like the real horrible stuff that
went on in Eastern Europe like Eastern
Europe is where the real horror shows
were when it came to the H deir that
wasir was was that hore is that how you
pronounce it the hore there's but
there's also that the marmaid has this
has this podcast about I forget what
it's called but it's about the horrors
of a particular communist group and I
I'm totally spacing on the name if the
chat knows I'm sure I'm sure the chat
knows because they know Martin's podcast
but it was it was about the things that
that the Communists did they were
absolute monsters and kids don't know
this because they didn't have cameras
like the way the Allies documented the
Nazi camps and the and Hitler kind of
documented his own behavior for the
world to see but like in in Soviet
Russia like a mute sounded like no this
is because of this is because of people
that believe in socialism so they didn't
report things in the west it is an
active intent to cover up the horrors
that's what red means yeah William
Durant was covering up the horrors that
the Soviet Union was doing Walter yeah
Walter Durant there there's been plenty
of people that were were Communists
believed in communism and then because
of that they covered up terrible things
that Communists have done because they
call them excesses and their their
attempts that you know attempts to to
produce the perfect Society love I love
how Durant actually was like there's no
need to actually investigate whether any
of these things are actually happening
God New York Times you be shocked man
it's wild I kid you not there are
students that I've talked to that tell
me Well communism just hasn't been imp
implemented in the correct way yet or or
or socialism hasn't it's it you know
Cuba Venezuela whatever it's just it
hasn't been done perfectly yet you know
if we just listened and implemented
socialism and communist ideals like it
could work in America and like that's
how far it's gotten in campuses I
remember my question regarding uh you
talking to people on the street um when
you speak to people are they are they
like do they do they realize what is
like how much like people always say
people on the man the street things they
only certain people that say dumb things
when you do this do you chop very much
material to make it I don't not trying
to out your for like what's the word
like uh unethical unethical journalism
but how many people do you meet that are
are informed that do know what's going
on versus how many people do you meet
that are like wow you're almost like a
lost cause like how many what's the
ratio to that CU that's that's what
really matters to me okay I will
honestly say gen Z is very 50/50 and it
also depends on the region what school
I'm going to so I just did a video and I
was at UCLA in Beverly Hills OH 90% I
asked the question is America racist and
I had almost every single person tell me
yes America's racist systemically you
know you can't be racist against white
people like whatever it is but then I go
to a school like you know I went to
University of Arizona down in Tucson I
asked just basic American based
questions and they could actually answer
American History questions so it's very
much it depends on what school it is
it's very very Regional um and a lot of
these kids are transplanter so you know
the kids go on UCLA are from all over
the place but they chose that for a
purpose uh Socialism or communism or
capitalism I mean those videos are
across the board we do choose and use
almost every single one of the answers
we get so when you see any of my Clips
it's not because I pick that person and
that person I'm like oh that's going to
go the most viral I mean I'll talk to
our protesters and I'll talk to people
inside of our events and genuinely try
to get you know what is jenzie thinking
that's always my focus is you know I
want to show the world this is what gen
Z college students from across the world
or Across the Nation actually think
about these issues and it is pretty
split you know I was at UCLA and I had a
girl reach out to me and she was like
Hey like I was really scared to answer
your questions but I actually am a
conservative and I feel like I can't
speak out so there are kids on these
campuses that are educated and are
informed but the problem is is they're
facing so much censorship they're facing
cancel culture they're facing you know
their college campuses their professors
absolutely hate them in their ideals I
mean Harvard Free Speech doesn't even
exist at Harvard University anymore and
so these kids fear so much to speak out
I mean nursing students having to learn
abortions and uh having to get you know
not going to say it but they're having
to bow down to these oligarchs really
that are controlling the universities so
they're so silent and they're so scared
I have an idea how about uh the parallel
economy forces
unify in a pledge to never hire from
this point forward anyone with a degree
from any of the major University Systems
only because I support a Road to
Redemption especially the UC system 100%
I'm going to say this yeah maybe like
for five years no cuz everybody can
become I I don't even say for five years
I'm like we re we can reassess when we
reassess like if the UC system comes out
and says like you know Long Live America
and flies the American flag big and bold
and says now everyone's required to take
a Constitution test and all that stuff
I'd be like oh we're good but right now
I'm thinking about these people you're
bringing up a conservative what what
what college was she at UCLA UCLA yeah I
would never hire her and I think I I
think no company should hire her I think
if she ever steps foot in a building and
says here's my look I went to UCL get
out like you mean to tell me that you
knew exactly what was going on and you
were like I'd love to have a degree from
this institution I mean that that's
that's like it if you're some regular
kid you got a degree and you're like
honestly I wasn't really following
politics I just wanted to do like you
know graphic design and stuff I'd be
like okay but if you're like oh I was a
conservative the whole time and I didn't
speak up but I wanted a degree from UCLA
I'll be like good luck getting a job in
Hollywood I wish you the best oh I mean
80% I would say honestly 70 80% of
college students that are conservative
on college campuses that aren't speaking
out they're exactly like that they are
just living their lives like I'll just
get through college you know I'll write
the paper I'll get the a and they are
willing to you
know who are you trying to impress the
Hollywood pet files no I mean like
you're going to UCLA to get a degree are
you you're trying to endear yourself to
the Hollywood pedophiles well I don't
want to hire you cuz their whole thing
is well then how do I get a job you know
if they don't get the degree and they
don't graduate and they don't get the
grades and they don't just like silence
themselves for four years then where do
they go and work well I I I can't speak
I can't speak for uh uh I can't speak
for uh jobs outside of media I can tell
you I have not asked about anyone's
college degree when when when hiring
here at timcast we have 42 employees uh
42 a handful of contractors so maybe
like 37 or 38 but I've not once been
like and where did you graduate college
from oh no I agree I think they should
College doesn't matter in reality it's a
piece of paper it's so meaningless where
if you actually have a craft and you
decide you know I actually instead want
to do this we have the world's knowledge
on our fingertips you can learn anything
I just I don't see uh like if you want
to be a doctor or a lawyer I mean I
understand there are certain things you
have to go to college War but of course
if you're like this is why I'm saying
parallel economy uh I'm not you don't
you don't you don't need any legal
requirements to work at a media company
you need to be good at what you do so if
you come to me for instance and say I'd
like to work at timcast and you're like
I just recently graduated from UCLA I'd
be like I'm not going to hire you who
are you trying to impress you're not
trying to impress me you want to impress
me tell me you dropped out of school and
figured out on your own look I got I got
to be honest it's not just about the the
UC system and these corrupt colleges
it's about in my experience somebody who
decides the path forward is to be told
what to do by institutionalized learning
facilities is not going to be as skilled
or driven as someone who figured it out
on their own they're not as critically
thought like the internet or the uh
college was good until about 1996 and
then the internet supplanted the the N
the nature like you said the the
information is now avable unless you can
go to college for like a conservatory if
you want to study like acting for for
four years and you pay a bunch of money
so that you get like six lead roles a
year and you're surrounded by good
actors and you get really good at it or
music or something like that that's a
different story like you said being a
doctor you want to go somewhere where
you can do the practice every day um
well there's legal requirements there I
can understand that and you're not
trying and and if you're going to set up
your own practice or work for someone
else they expect you to have that qual
people that haven't figured it out that
are still going through the motions are
not critical thinkers not on the level
that you need to really get your
business ahead the hyperpolarization is
too pronounced at this point I mean when
Joy Reed I Love This Joy Reed was was
debating the mom one of one of the
people from moms for Liberty one of one
of the women and asked was asked about
adult objects appearing in books Joy
read defended children having access to
this but the joy read X account censored
the word because the general public
which is primarily
adults should not see this word but
children should when we're dealing with
someone like that okay when you go to
one of these major universities because
you think you need a
degree I don't know who you're trying to
impress because it ain't impressing me
okay now if you if you went to like some
very Christian University or whatever
because they exist or a private or one
of these newer ones they're anti-woke
and you explain I went here for this
reason I'd be I'd be like oh wow okay
that's cool um it's more valuable to me
if someone came to me and said I'm a
video editor and let's say I'm like I
need a video editor and they came to me
and said here's a bunch of stuff I've
made I'd be like wow this is really cool
stuff can you make more great you're
hired there's no circumstance where I'm
like but hold on I do like that video
but where did you go to school that that
make that's a completely meaningless
tell me about your parents before I hire
you you problem with the college degree
system is because they graduate college
with absolutely zero experience in the
real world they don't have critical
thinking skills they don't know how to
think they because they've been told
their whole life what to think yes
that's the problem I'll give sh shout
out to Carter Banks our music producer I
don't even know if he went to school or
not he just made a video where he was
like hey hire me and then a few months
later Ian was like yo check out this
video and I was like oh wow this is a
really good video we should hire this
guy yes and we did he will do more of
that and he certainly does so I think
Jen Z should go and learn a craft if
you're passionate about something go
master that craft be really really good
at it and then go do it we have to build
the parallel economy that's really
that's it I mean you like you don't need
a degree to be a journalist you don't
need a degree to go on TV no it's kind
of crazy that right now a lot of these
genen genz people uh uh younger younger
genz people are like I need to go to
college to get a degree and there's this
viral meme on Tik Tok where it's a guy
sitting on a bench and he's like I
forgot what it was it was like me with
my economics degree watching an illegal
immigrant get Free Housing and free food
and and and he's just like well it's
true you're graduating with unemployed
meting on a park bench while illegal
immigrants are getting free money and
I'm just like yeah you're in debt you
can't afford anything the degree was
worthless they lied to you man like it
shows the guy in the economics classroom
like third year in macroeconomics
studying and then the other guy on his
phone like third year trading Bitcoin
I'm at 7.7 billion like you talk about
real econom I'll tell you guys one of
the one of the stories I've often
mentioned I knew somebody who was in
college third year music business major
and we were hanging out and I was I was
like so I was like oh blah blah talking
oh you're doing music business and then
I was like so what do you do like what
does music business mean like record
label stuff and they were telling me
like yeah you know like record label
deals uh uh uh setting up shows things
like that and I was like oh cool how
many shows have you set up and she's
like none and I was like none you've
been in college for three years for
music business and you've not done any
shows she's like no we're learning and I
was like they don't teach how I'm a high
school dropout and I've set up three or
four already yeah I'm not even
interested in music business my friends
were just wanting to do a show and so I
called around some venues and talked to
the owner about setting up a show you
mean that I have more experience in the
workforce than you how much money do you
spend 30,000 a year jez dude some
ridiculous number a lot of the schools
are teaching the kids or the people the
adults how things used to work learn and
things are changing so rapidly yeah like
in 2 years AI is going to completely
transition the game of making music
making painting art that kind of stuff
imagine going to school for a computer
science and learning how to program but
you can learn how to program actually in
real time now just on your laptop not to
mention you're talking about like the
economics meme the affirmative action
policies you have these kids that are
graduating colleges every single year
hundreds of thousands of kids if not
millions and they can't even get a job
in this job market because they it's
impossible with affirmative action
policies in the these corporations plus
they don't want to hire you because you
have absolutely zero experience but how
are you supposed to get experience
that's why you have so many college
educated people that are waiting tables
and working these noname like useful
jobs that we need in our country but you
know they thought that going to college
and they bought into the LIE they bought
into the scam and they're going to spend
and getting more debt to get a PhD to
get a master's that hundreds of
thousands of other people are getting
mbas too and they're going to be stuck
doing absolutely nothing they're going
to be going hello sir I have nothing
unique about me I have the exact same
qualifications as 10,000 other people
pick me i' be a well that is why I
dropped out of college when people go to
college or when young people go to
college I feel like they go too
frequently with no idea what they're
going to do so they they take like a
liberal arts degree or whatever they
have they're not going with the intent
of learning a specific thing and
obviously this is not everybody so don't
if you're going to learn something don't
think not every comment I make is for
everyone but there are a there are too
many people that go to college with no
idea what they want to do and those
people would be far better served
learning to do something like learning a
trade or something because you don't
have to do the trade forever but at the
very least you get out of the shorter
and less expensive school that you were
in with the ability to actually do
something and if you want to do
something else you can have this trade
to at least provide you with the ability
to make a living and pay for your pay
for your roof over your head and stuff I
don't you guys I I love learning in a
way I wasn't like that in my 20s I in my
20s I was just waiting for school to be
over with but now like I enjoy learning
the data and putting the pieces together
in a new way so you can always go to
college when you're older if you really
want to go but I mean you just don't
need that kind of an well not everyone
needs that kind of intensified learning
environment also I love learning but I
don't think that college is actually
fostering intelligence anymore so I I uh
uh have done video editing edited Vlogs
edited documentaries edited many
documentaries I never went to school for
video editing when I was 14 I started
using Premiere to make skate videos I
also used uh Shockwave because uh
anybody remember what Shockwave was yeah
you actually audio thing but you could
do video too and so there were some
elements of it I could use for video
editing I didn't know work care and I I
used uh macr media Flash before it came
became Adobe and to uh to make websites
because I wanted to and I learned how to
do all these things and then here I am
working media video editing back in the
day where they'd have like multiple and
the tape de you had to go like learn how
to turn the wheels to slow down one tape
and cut I remember doing that a lot of
me feels like the the the fact that
people don't have that kind of gut
feeling that they're free come is part
of the fact that people kind of don't
have the gut feeling that I can go try
this you know it's that it's like they
don't have the the impulse to be like oh
let me go ahead and try doing this and
make mistakes and mess up and
learn you know by by experimenting as
opposed to they feel like they need some
kind of formal training formal
instruction they've been told their
whole life that they have to go to
college this is how to think you're this
is what to think and then you're going
to graduate and have no idea what you're
doing you go to college to find yourself
but you end up losing yourself and
having no idea what you want to do with
your life we're going to go to super
chats so if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with all of your friends and family
members tell them it's the best show
ever everyone agrees at least that's
what I've been told and head over to
timcast.net uncensored members only show
will be live at 10 p.m. tonight and it's
always good fun you as members actually
get to call in to talk to us granted you
need to sign up I think well before the
show submit your questions and then we
bring about five callers in every night
so it is a tight fit but uh please
engage with us not only that as a member
of the Discord you get to hang out for
the pre-shows the after shows everyone
in there they're all arguing with each
other it's just a lot of fun and so we
encourage all of that rules yeah it's
good fun it's good fun but now now we
will read your super chats all right big
7588 with the first Super Chat saying
education can fix America's Healthcare
problem you're you're right but I do
think education uh uh means cultural
issues as well right like we need a
culture of people who aren't gorging
themselves yo look I got to be honest we
went out for lunch for dinner I don't
know what you call it it was like 2:30
or 3 3 p.m. what is that that's dinner
right or supper lunch dinner supper I
don't know and I was like I'm going to
get a cheeseburger you know I have I
don't eat a lot of bread but I was like
I think I'll just you know I'm going to
have a cheeseburger today because I I do
I I don't like the absolute elimination
stuff where it's like I just do keto
only like Monday the only thing I ate
was
salami just salami no like literally
nothing but salami I had two protein
shakes and a bunch of salami and it was
awesome and I love it because it's like
it's uncooked or whatever but then I'm
like no then then I'll have something
regular the next day yo it was too big
there was like it was this big it was a
burger that that like it was that big
and then you turn it and it's like that
and I'm like I don't know how to bite
this why I would get I would I would
break the rules and get a fork and knife
to eat a cheese I was thinking like if I
had known it was going to be this big
I'd have split it with my girlfriend
would and we would have been happy to do
so cuz I'm like this has got to be like
2,000 calories and it was like it was it
was like a higher end Place Al's head
like a restaurant not like a fast food
place it was like a actual restaurant
yeah it was ridiculous so you know we
want to make America better our health
problem people got to learn how to eat
better get rid of the gigantic portions
that I mean I understand like more
protein in your diet yeah definitely oh
I learned this this is crazy I did not
realize man people do not get enough
protein in their diet no oh not at all
and I've I've I I've known that as a
general fact but I didn't realize how
much so I started tracking my protein
and I was low and I was like how can
that be possible I have two protein
shakes every day not enough nope a
single scoop of protein powder is 20 to
24 uh gram of protein and you need like
60 or more more way more than that if
you're trying if you're exercising and
you want to if you're exercising and
doing doing like uh cardio so you're
burning a lot of calories as well as as
lifting weights or whatever and you want
to just maintain the weight that you
have and not lose muscle mass you should
be eating at least one gram of protein
per pound of body weight that means I
need to eat like 175 gram just to
maintain if you want actually gain
muscle in the most efficient way you can
you need at least 1.5 gam of protein per
one that's crazy cuz I was I was I was
averaging like 50 and then I I read that
if if I'm being sedentary and not
exercising it's like 70 and so I'm like
I should do two protein shakes every day
and then I tried doing a double scoop it
was disgusting do you drink do you have
milk with them uh no but I put cream I
put cream in it so uh so I got casin
protein Y and cuz people in the chat
were like drink casin at night so I've
been doing a Cas protein shake before
bed I do uh ja mul the best protein
powder I've ever had I you know I'm they
don't pay me to endorse but holy crap
it's the best you will ever have no
question what about Cricket protein
disgusting uh but the the the jao milk
stuff is a it's like I think it's wayy
Cas there's no artificial sweetener
garbage in it it's monk fruit it's like
actual yeah so I'm like thank you jao
knows what's up and so been doing one of
I do one of those I do it and that's
only that's only like 45 44 45 grams of
protein and then I'm just like damn I
try and get four big glasses of of milk
a day because that's about 80 grams of
protein if you have four of them and
that's just that's that's on the raw
milk train no no this is crazy though
look the other people intolerant I drink
the super processed milk we skated I I
think we skated on Monday yeah it was
Monday and uh after I'm done Suns
skating I immediately make a a protein
shake it's uh I think it's probably like
a pint of of water I do about
probably I don't know like an e/ cup of
cream and then a scoop of protein powder
of jackco milk and then I drink that
fairly quickly then I uh uh the next day
no soreness at all yeah everybody else
they like I I'm too sore to skate I
can't skate I'm tired protein the yeah
the thing is if you if you're
experiencing like excessive muscle from
exercising and stuff add more protein
and if you Tim you might want to try uh
adding skim milk instead of water
because it's super thin it's it's got
consist but it's got extra protein too
so skim milk might might be something
you want to try I don't know into it or
milk huh I'm adding fat to the shake
well you could add more you could add
whole milk if you wanted yes but you but
try there's a lot of sugar and whole
milk try making it with the try making
the uh try making the shape with shake
with with uh skim yeah got like Fair
life has like 50% less sugar and stuff
like that I drink so much fair life I
got you're lactose intolerant right like
I am as well yeah and i' also my my acid
reflux and stuff is really oh it helps
so much God have you tried A2 milk same
similar thing it's got the lactase
enzyme added to it basically so
different cows let's move on we'll read
some more Super chats because we're
getting wrapped up in diet stuff but I'm
also excited for the cold plunge that we
just got oh yeah oh yeah and uh we went
to uh this like heated heated pool at
this Resort and we're rolling around me
and Richie Jackson were rolling around
in the snow then jumping in the pool
like over and over again and it was
probably really bad for us but I don't
know you got you got to we got to read
more fig out what temperature you're
going to do the cold Plunge at not there
yet why don't you set it up all right
let's read more all right fraus says
vake and Lake
2028 that'll be fun you think car Lake's
goingon to be Trump's VP I'm a v girl me
too except I'm not a girl I don't the
challenge though is the VP needs to be
someone who gets new votes so like
that's true bergham actually makes sense
I I I think Trump's so famous he doesn't
need any new votes I think V can get the
genz votes though yeah he does yep
that's the solution genen Z is going to
be the largest voting block going into
2024's election there's no other
candidate that's actually talking to
genen Z other than and he had uh the
highest number of firsttime Voters in
Iowa exactly that's a good point
actually Trump you want to get the Jen Z
vote VC and I think you can actually
talk to the more moderate Democrat
liberal people that are on college
campuses and get them to change their
minds anybody who likes car Lake likes
Trump true you know it's so VI makes a
lot of sense cuz yeah he actually does
get a lot of younger people all right
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim it's a
beautiful thing to see States backing
Texas it's about time state government
stood up to a corrupt federal government
it can lead to bad things but it needs
to be done so I say forward the line
here here yeah here here it's an
ex-marine saying that too Pierce wor
saying hey Tim I was at Daily Mass this
morning my priest mentioned we are in a
civil war and talked about talked about
it the FBI watching Christian
conservatives and people who bought
Bibles that's right I wonder if he
watches the show the federal government
was was spying on people asking
financial institutions to track those
who bought Bibles like guys what do you
think they're doing that for and where
do you think that leads the the like
this this goes back to what we were
saying earlier you know there there all
the stuff that you concerned about that
you talked about earlier that we were
saying oh maybe in the future they've
already done it the tracking mechanisms
have been in place for like 20 years
look how they were shutting down
churches in 2020
yeah it's all the it's all it's all
built in all right here's a very a very
important one to follow up quy Joe says
Tim uh uh what he says sorry he didn't
say my name he said what is your
favorite Tony Hawk game and why three
why it was when things got smoothed out
I believe it was the PS3 it was when it
got you you you had a PS3 version it
introduced bamar jera it introduced
reverts and flips but it didn't get to
the point where after that it got so
insanely complicated and it just got
weird it was still arcade it was still a
lot of fun the airport best level but
also Canada was a pretty good level Tony
Haw 3 that was my favorite I mean Tony
Haw 2 is the classic tonw one's like
yeah it's fun Tony Haw 2 was like this
game is a classic tony3 is my favorite
what about you I only played one of them
it was in like 1996 and it was on the
PS1 no you didn't then I played a
skateboard game back then maybe skater
die in '96 no you played skater die in
the Nintendo in the 8 though cuz the
first Tony hot game I believe was 99
skater die was awesome SK two player was
sweet constantly going
downhill all right let's grab some more
Super chats mearian s says Tulsi gabed
for VP that will send Dems into a frenzy
and get some Dems and a lot of libs that
is true telsey gabard will get a lot of
the anti-war liberal
vote maybe she she what I would if she
was going to be VP she's got to start
making more noise right
now you know she I I believe she is one
of the better contenders it makes sense
uh uh military service uh uh political
service she got experience and she she
attacks uh uh politically in areas that
Democrats are are trying to
control you know like Tulsi gabard would
be U would work for money for for
moderate moderate liberal
types makes sense I'm not saying she's
the best I think the is pretty
good all right let's grab some more
Super chats let's see where we are
alahad says hi Tim Tom McDonald and Ben
Shapiro song this Friday oh
boy Ben Shapiro and Tom McDonald did a
song I didn't know they did a song
together well we we we were talking to
uh I don't know what they ended up doing
but Ben plays violin yeah so you know I
I had I had this idea too I've never
heard of he I bet he's so good you know
I want to jam with him though that's
awesome he's very good we we we we had
pitched this last year we never actually
got around to it so I hope they actually
pull off something um because it should
be done but I was like we got to get
like Michael NES Ben Shapiro uh Jack
bobic James O'Keefe because they all
play music they they're all musicians
and just you know own the libs it'd be
funny should go on tour make a song
called owning the libs by Ben Shapiro
Michael nolles Jack bobic Tim P Ian
crosslin fanti um Cassandra just
messaged that Glenn yunan posted on
Twitter Virginia stand with Texas oh
yeah this is on Glen yin's official
Twitter account from 5 minutes ago bet
oror posted the opposite but nobody
cares about him so interesting of course
book posted the opposite maybe we'll
pull this up but it says Greg Abbott uh
Texas is doing the job Joe Biden and his
bordar refused to do to secure our
border the Biden administration's turned
every state into a border state we must
stop the flow of fentanyl save lives and
secure our Southern border wow shout out
Glenn yunan wow he's not been the best
but you know he
doing enough you know and someone just
mentioned yesterday Glenn yunin has ex
like really really really high approval
rating in uh in Virginia um the point
that they made was look all you have to
be is like not a crazy person and you'll
get you'll get a great you'll get you'll
get you know treated well but so the
fact that he is looked at as reasonable
by most by his constituents and and is
not thought of as a Maga extremist or
what ever um although obviously anyone
that goes and says that they support
Texas the media will be immediately
sliming them tomorrow so you expect
expect hit Pieces by by the end of the
week onever they're going to say look at
all these Southern States yeah exactly I
mean exactly like you said like you said
this today they they pointed out
Southern intentionally to make that
connection to the Civil War in slavery
um J all right genx Statesman says as a
Texan my only real question is this will
I get to see the Civil War movie before
the Civil War we we we we mentioned this
before the show we were getting
production set up I was like wouldn't it
be funny if right before the movie comes
out the country breaks up into the exact
map of the movie dude I know the only
thing missing be California I don't know
how they're going to they're going to
seced with like Florida Florida Texas
right no the the the map had five had
five factions it had uh uh the Western
forces the Western it had the southern
states then it had Texas and California
and then the loyal Estates right so
Texas California became their own
countries yeah and the the the republics
of California and Texas were aligned in
so far as they were defending their
sovereignty from the Union right or at
least that's what I believe that the
trailer is the story is so far we'll see
when's that movie coming out do we know
I was wondering that today I have no
idea I will go see that movie I wonder
if it'll make a billion dollars like
nobody want I I I Aquaman came out the
other day right looks like it's
scheduled to be April 12th so I I was I
I'll watch Aquaman holy crap do you know
what Aquaman 2 is about the bad guy is
trying to warm the planet to make Global
warm you're joking I'm not kidding they
he discovers this ancient technology
that uses this fuel first we will heat
the oceans then the world no he finds
ancient technology he's trying to he
wants revenge on Aquaman he finds
ancient technology and then the
scientist working for him is like this
used to be all ice and he goes man they
God for global warming and like yes then
he finds these technology and this like
this creature is like you know this bad
the bad guy is like find the fuel and
then revive me and so then he steals
this fuel from Atlantis and these raids
and then it's called oricalcum and then
they you know they're asking like you
know Aquaman's like why are they
stealing this Fuel and they're like back
when we were a younger civilization we
were using fuel that released a lot of
greenhouse gases and was destroying the
planet but we learned and we couldn't
properly of it so he stored it safely
and guarded it and now he's taking it
and then they find out he's been warming
the planet and they're like what's
causing these plagues underwater and
it's like the planet's being warmed over
the past several months I'm not kidding
like yo it's wild it's the stupidest
thing I've ever seen that's so annoying
I really hope their box office numbers
are just down the drain oh it was it was
it was really really bad you want to
look up the box office for Aquaman too I
think it was please do apocal I read
about Ora calom it's an actual thing
that's why nobody watches Hol from the
story of Atlantis apparently it's a gold
resembled gold but its value is inferior
were you looking at box office of
what yeah really really bad cringe is it
still what's his name is the Aquaman
yeah kogo Jason Mamoa what's the bo like
Mamoa 3
373 million wow with a potential
lifetime Hall of 400 million culture is
is fractured like the Marvel movies are
done nobody cares no one's watching them
so I tried to watch the Marvels because
I'm like I'm not going to go see in
theaters but it's like it was it was we
we went to this Resort and they headed
on the TV it is awful is this the woman
one like the feminist garbage yeah it's
horrible no but
like wow made for home
DVD for real like the villain it was
like played by a woman who never acted
before or something I was just like wow
jez dude like I'll be honest the the the
the young woman who plays Kam L Khan
she's she's really good the uh uh Brie
Larson actually also really good like
I'm not a big fan of her I think she's a
wrong character for the role but the
acting is like on par with Hollywood no
the when who played the villain I was
just like I don't think she's actually
acting like it feels like someone copy
and pasted themselves into the movie CU
they wanted to be in it I'm not trying
to be a dick da disrespect that's a
feature that that's a phenomenon that
happens a lot writers write themselves
into movies as the hero and it usually
means that it's going to be a bad movie
but I mean like the woman couldn't act
like she doesn't fit it's it's like
someone superimposing themselves over
job of the hut to be like I am job of
the Hut and you're like that's not real
I'm glad you shouted out Brie Larson
because I think she's very talented and
has been put in some horrible roles or
accepted some horrible roles she's had
some real bad PR kind of nasty the PR
but yeah bad role bad role all right
let's read some more let's read some
more you're uh what does it say Ursa
arvite Tucker's statement was dumb how
about Tucker use his massive following
and platform to help us mobilize it
cannot just be a few Texans going down
there need to be many need to be uh we
need to help
organizing you
know I don't know exactly what should be
done but what I can tell you what you
can do is make
money hope for the best prepare for the
worst so we're in West Virginia I think
we got to take care of our communities
and it's and it would be silly I do
think it would be silly for like West
Virginia or Virginia to Rush full speed
to Texas to organize whatever Texas will
deal with Texas and we'll give them our
support from afar like we're seeing now
with the governors
we like it would be absurd if everyone
just flocked to one state because then
you're basically centralizing all
everything and then they could just
Crush you that way you need to make
Virginia great again make Oklahoma make
West Virginia work on your states to
improve them and do what you can to help
make your community stronger because if
things get dark the people who live near
you and around you you guys got to be
organized
yourselves but uh man Church used to be
that you know people would go to church
and all right let's uh let's let's grab
some more here Ziri says I'm looking for
help my father almost died earlier this
month having his second leg amputated he
is one of the many affected by the water
at Camp how do you how do you pronounce
it l leun I'm trying to reach VI or
Trump seeing as Biden has failed him
there's a I have no idea there are um
ads that I hear regular about about the
camp leun um water situation so Google
the camp leun you or you should you
should Google the class action lawsuit
about the water at Camp leun I hear ads
there's there's programs where there is
lawsuits that you can get it you know
make yourself a part of or whatever to
hopefully help give you a hand all right
Ryan the eating Warriors has good luck
owning a house now the only people that
could get a home in a few years will be
the people making 150k Plus or an
illegal immigrant that has been gifted a
house by the US government chaos will
erupt yo when I was trying to buy my
first house I was denied by
everybody and it was
actually pretty crazy cuz I'm like hey
I've worked for these big companies I
run my own company here's how much money
I'm making and uh this was after fusion
and they said you're unemployed we will
not give you a loan and I was like I'm
not unemployed I'm self-employed and
they're like What's the difference yep
they really want you to work for someone
else it's safer fortunately uh my bank
who I'd been with for like a decade said
we know how much money you have we know
how much money comes in we know what
jobs you've had this is a safe bet for
us and I was able to get a loan to buy a
house when we were trying to come out
here same problem and at this point I'm
like okay now I have a top 100 podcast
I'm making lots and lots of money I
could buy a house in cash and they were
like sorry no loan and then it took
months and then finally after like it
was really weird like different agents
kept handing us off dropping the call
and I was like something weird is going
on it isn't that crazy like you have the
collateral in hand like you could
literally be like I will open a bank
account at your bank and put this money
into the account as collateral they
don't care and and it's crazy I think it
had a lot to do with what we're seeing
with these big investment firms buying
up property they're thinking to
themselves I don't I don't care to do a
loan with this guy because these big
institutions it's much much easier for
them to just buy and and the price are
like what's the point MH but I I I
wonder if part of it is conspiratorial
they don't want young people buying
houses oh they don't want you to own
anything yeah they want you to own
nothing and be happy and so when I come
along and I'm like I want to buy this
house they're like no so actually what
ended up happening is uh the the place
we're in now is not it's not personally
my house it's the studio it's where we
do everything so I actually ended up
having to buy a house the house I ended
up buying I did buy in cash cuz no one
will give me a loan for it and I'm like
I'm talking to these different Brokers
and I said listen man I I was like you
got to you got to break this down for me
how am I not able to get a loan for a
house and they're like well you know the
economic factors and your credit score I
like my credit score is some of the best
it's one of the best in the country
they're like well you know and then I
was like I'm I'm just going to say it
I'm like my guy I'm a millionaire I
don't want to just drop the money on the
house I'm trying to get a loan through
your institution sorry we can't help you
and and I was just like holy crap so I
wrote a check I bought it in cash now
look I'm I'm not saying it to brag I'm
saying that something is wrong in this
country yeah when I struggled to get a
loan for a house I told the guys I was
like listen dropping all that money at
once is is risky and scary because it's
basically like my retirement my savings
like this is what I have I have it saved
up I could buy a house with it but if I
do a loan I understand I'm giving the
bank money but allows me to budget more
effectively for emergencies and multiple
institutions said absolutely I wonder if
they were like yo because of inflation
because of all the money that was
printed in a year your $6,000 a month
loan repayment is going to be worth
$5,400 so we're just going to hold on
we're going to take 800,000 now and
spend it before it becomes worth 680,000
that's that's exactly it one of the
reasons that I'm thinking like a loan is
good is because if the buying power of a
dollar is dropping dramatically due to
inflation and covid having a loan is is
great because the debt becomes worthless
and that's probably why they're like
we're not giving out loans right now I
took out a loan right before the uh
right before Co happened to build a
studio or right was right in the
beginning of cod to build the studio at
chicke the place that we got because I
was like inflation's coming I was like
like I know it and now you know it's
worked out really really well because
you know I built a whole studio and how
how is J going to buy houses I not
physically Jen Z will not be able to
afford houses I was watching a video
that the amount of money that you make
versus the average cost of what you need
to have a house has completely
flip-flopped that gen Z now you're
making like 80,000 70,000 if you're
lucky a year and you can hardly afford
you know you're buying a shoe box
apartment for two grand a month plus
your living expenses they're they have
no savings yeah majority of jenzi has no
savings they're not going to be able to
buy houses but they don't want them to
all right Omega retsu says Tim the US
has not been a constitutional republic
since before the Civil War uh since
before the Civil War since then the US
has been a federal republic look up
federal republic in interesting makes
sense makes sense reconstruction
occupation Etc yeah let's grab some
more YouTube's been really busted up
it's I'm like I thought maybe something
was wrong with the memory on the
computer it's not no it's not it's
YouTube itself yeah it's the YouTube
back end is like does not work I know
exactly what you
mean all right I'm trying and grab some
more Super chats but I'm having trouble
scrolling yes yep super weird I don't
know what's going on with it man yeah
all right here we go we got a good one
here let's see if I can actually read it
Phil Parnell says I'm active duty USAF
Staff Sergeant I don't know a single
troop who is supporting this
Administration some aren't very big
Trump supporters and many really really
like V the vake but Trump is definitely
the favorite in the enlisted I mean that
makes sense y stick says these corrupt
deals behind closed doors with
politicians are funded by Black Books
the Intel agencies tied with cartels
make money from what is happening at the
border K Lake would shut down their
gravy train I want to tell you I made
this point earlier on one of my morning
segments talking about this when he says
back East it's what I'm being told so uh
I hear from uh many of the the people in
gaming that MGM National Harbor is the
highest grossing Casino in the country I
don't know that that's true what I do
know is the games at MGM are some of the
most expensive games I've ever seen and
I can't believe it you want to play
Blackjack 50 bucks whoa like you can get
you'll get lucky if you find a $25 per
hand table wow yeah but and and even
more and I'm walking by and I like a
roulette table and I'm like $100 minimum
bet and I'm like who is playing at this
casino you go upstairs to Poker and it's
13 one $1 $3 it's a relatively cheap
game to play just you know look you got
you're going to buy in between I think
100 and 500 bucks so you got to be able
to afford that but I asked somebody
familiar with the gaming industry why
the games are so expensive and uh I
don't know this is true so I want to
make sure that's clear MGM seems like a
fine establishment but he said dirty
politics money
laundering you're a few miles outside of
DC makes sense somebody somebody needs
to figure out a deal so here I'll give
you a scenario that I'm not saying it's
any one casino that does this how could
a foreign dignitary Emissary Diplomat
corporate executive give a 100 Grand to
an American political
entity can't hand that money off no it's
illegal you can't wire transfer it it's
illegal tell you what you can do you can
lose it to him in poker you absolutely
can lose it to him in poker exactly yep
Ian caught it right away do you have to
pay taxes the wi got P just a just a 30%
some tax that's right 28% on on gambling
winnings so what happens is they go up
to the they go they go to these poker
rooms legal totally legal and they say I
want to play a high stakes game
$100,000 they buy in the recipient Buys
in and then all they have to do is wait
for the right moment where it's really
easy the recipient says when I scratch
my nose it means I've got the best hand
and then the guy who's giving the bribe
says got it they play a game of poker
for a couple hours the board runs out
the the recipient scratches his nose and
then the the the briber goes I'm I'm all
in and shoves 100 Grand in the middle of
the table and then the guy who's
supposed to receive the bribe goes ha
your bluff won't work on me I've got the
nuts I call the guy gave him the bribe
goes a a you got me you just won a
$100,000 off me fair and square and
completely legally sir drat uh make sure
when you're file when you're passing
this bill that's going to benefit my
company you dot the eyes and cross the
teas because I don't want to come back
and pay again and then they do it where
the cameras are off and then they just
do the you could do that on camera and
get that but if you do it enough times
on camera people might take
notice no but but it's but all the
casino got cameras everywhere but the
point is if they ever come to you and
say why did this guy this guy give you
money he didn't give me money he lost in
poker how dare you imply as a gift I won
fair and square that's my money it gives
you plausible deniability they can't
prove that it was a bribe they can't
prove that he that you knew you were
going to win or that he that he you know
that there was anything going on they
can't prove it and if they can't prove
it yeah you just need that Reasonable
Doubt man just a little bit of
reasonable doubt I'm I'm for it you know
not just not just that but even if you
were just to go into a casino and go to
the bar and slide someone a couple
pumpkins those are th000 chips if the
person leaving cashes those out he just
says oh I won and what are they goingon
to do track down the cameras of exactly
when it happened they don't even do that
so
pumpkins they got crazy bigger ones all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends tell them all it is
the best show everyone agrees at least
that's what I've been told and become a
member at
timcast.net g o NN and yes that is my
real name right on I am Phil that
remains on Twix I'm Phil that remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains you can follow us on
Spotify Apple music Amazon music Pandora
YouTube you know the internet oh and the
left lane is for crime and I'm Ian
Crossland uh your chat was wild today I
really enjoyed popping in and reading
what you guys are typing so keep it up
keep doing it I love it I'll see you
later yeah chat is always wild I love
you guys in chat you're cool um I'm
surge.com let's go to the after show
we'll see you all over at timcast.net